greetings humanoids youtube annoyed
welcome to the podcast
my guest today is really quite an
extraordinary human his name is
hakim tafari and i don't quite know
how to adequately describe him how to
capture him in words
he is a unique and amazing soul and he
does many things his story is remarkable
it's beautiful but ultimately i think i
would characterize him as
a seeker a sort of journeyman of
reinvention
he's an ambassador of running culture
and mindfulness
he's a master of many a martial art from
kung fu to tai chi
he's also an herbalist a massage
therapist a vegan
a father and a student and a
practitioner of many
a spiritual path from buddhism to taoism
and essentially everything in between
over the years i've had the pleasure of
conversing with
quite a few incredible people and every
once in a while
i end up clicking with someone in a very
particular way that seems to take
everything to
the next level into this other gear
and i would characterize this as one
such experience
how come is full of heart and truth and
vulnerability and authenticity and i
think that's pretty much
all i want to say other than to urge you
to remain for the entire conversation as
hakem really takes us on this
journey that i don't think you will soon
forget
i know that i won't if you enjoy this
channel please click that subscribe
button
and hit that notification bell so you
can be properly alerted
with every new video that publishes and
thank you for that and with that i give
you
the singular hakim to fare
cheers man welcome to the podcast studio
thank you
so good to have you here man uh
it's so funny because we just met yeah
and the circumstances around how we met
are so bizarre
yeah we shot this little commercial
video for jaybird we both worked with
jaybird
and part of that project was
us encountering each other as if we were
like
lifelong buddies yeah so we had to go
into a little bit of a method acting
to do it yeah um but i had so much fun
hanging out with you all day and i just
thought this would be great man
you have an amazing story and so i'm
delighted to have you here today to
share a little bit about it thank you
for having me and then in the wake of
that
you go off to we're trying to schedule
the date and you're like i'm going to be
out of town and i'm checking your
instagram and you're hanging out in
montana with conrad anchor
yeah what were you doing out there so um
i'll give you this a little brief
because obviously i'm held to
this nda thing that they uh but um
secret top secret yeah it's kind of top
secret
um but it was an amazing amazing time
um in fact i didn't know that i was
gonna be hanging out with conrad until
like a week before
um but i got a call for the special
project and we're like yeah
um we'd really want you to come out to
wyoming
it's going to be based around i saw
montana it was wyoming wyoming
that's okay okay um so they said you
know we want you to come out
it's going to be this crazy project
you're going to be here with a whole
bunch of people that you don't know
and um conrad's going to lead this
expedition and we're going to do gannett
but we ended up doing wolverine uh the
wild tetons and
got to hang out with some indigenous
folk and
yeah the rest was history and um
kg about what exactly like i get it
um you know they were like you know keep
your mouth shut
i gotcha you can only share a little bit
but you shared enough
uh for me to gather that you bonded with
conrad i mean what a beautiful
guy that guy is that guy is treasurer
he yeah he is a living treasure and you
know
i was just talking about him today um
he really is he's like a
a monk on a mountain mm-hmm he's a monk
on a mountain he's like a real
bodhisattva
and in the aspect that he is so
free-giving
and his knowledge and this is
his wisdom his compassion is just
and we had this running joke and i was
like i don't really look up to a lot of
middle-aged white men i really don't
i'll be the first one to tell you and
you're like he's my mentor now
yeah but conrad is literally like my
mentor he's like
you know there was a couple of
experiences i had on the hike and
you know he was just there with me and
he was literally like my ob1
you know he was all my yoda so to speak
and we were in the dagobah system and i
was just
teaching me the ways what do you make of
that i mean what is it about him
that's so special you think
you know i get the human experience i
get the human experience with conrad
like
there's not a lot of people that you
meet offhand
right off the bat and you can tell it's
very very authentic
it's very very genuine and you can tell
that he's lived so many lives
and within those so many lives he's had
so many experiences that have led him to
where he's at right now yeah and that's
what's beautiful about
just being around him i mean for people
that are listening or watching who
who aren't familiar with who he is i
mean he's probably
the the greatest living uh
mountaineer climber in the world he's
done everything he's
he has lived nine lives it's incredible
yeah um
and he's so giving to the younger
generation like the whole
kind of expedition community just
reveres him oh yeah
totally and you know one of the things
and we'll probably get into a little bit
late but one of the things that we
talked about
um and this was literally after just
like three days meeting him
and we just bonded right and when
when i left he was like we're gonna do
something to bring
black and latinx folks to the mountains
yeah i was like i'm with it let's
do it that's needed i mean it it sort of
is the purview of the uh
older white dude i mean that's something
i talked with
with myrna about as well with respect to
her relationship with with trail running
that
you know these pursuits are
traditionally so white
you know and that's got it that's got to
change yeah so how do we do that
coming in we bring hawk in
right yeah i'm like let's go we're
hitting this space that space in this
space
uh-huh yeah well it's quite a trajectory
an
arc of your life i mean there's so many
uh it's hard to get a grip on your story
because there's so many permutations to
it but
when you look at point a from where you
came from and kind of
all the things that you've done over the
course of your life to end up
like on a mountain with conrad or
shooting television commercials for
for jaybird yeah it's pretty amazing
right yeah
and in the amount of time that it's i
mean in the grand scheme of things
you know i'm 46 years old but in the
last six seven years has just been
right it's cool yeah and i think in
reflecting
you know as i was driving over here
trying to wrap my head around you and
your story
it's all an outgrowth of
the um investment that you've made
in your own personal spiritual
development right like these are these
are outward manifestations
of what has been very much an inward
journey for you
most definitely yeah so let's let's take
it back let's go all the way back to the
beginning
i want to hear about it oh man ipswich
so i was born and raised in ipswich uh
it's a little uh
town right outside of london it's about
hour and hour and a half outside of
london
uh i think ipswich is most known for
ipswich town fc
which is a football club which was
really big in
the uh late 70s early 80s
um they were a premiership league team
um and that was really the big thing
about ipswich we had a great football
team right
um and for the american listeners that's
soccer
because i think they're getting it yeah
as we're all falling in love with your
accent which feels like you're right out
of a guy richie movie
so and your parents are of jamaican
descent yeah my parents are jamaican
descent
um they came to england in the 60s
uh my dad is a jack-of-all-trades as far
as welder and mechanic
um he did everything and then my mother
came over here as a nurse
and ended up being becoming a
psychiatric nurse
and um that was a weird scene um
you know having to pick up my mom from a
mental institution
you know in the in the late in the late
70s early 80s and just
i remember that was just
very surreal um very surreal
so yeah so you know growing up in
ipswich
um going to a predominantly all-white
you know elementary school um
and then going to a very not so diverse
high school
and what kind of kid were you
well i would say i was up until i
reached high school i was a pretty
hands-on books kid right my parents have
drilled it into me
uh they were like you know we didn't get
the college show
you're making sure that you're going to
college right and it's starting from now
so they were very very you know hands-on
make sure you get your books your
homework done stuff like that
and then high school happened
so uh during high school i had cousins
who were older than me and they were
kind of like my protectors right and
everyone knew my cousins
from that school and then i had cousins
you know that's the thing with ipswich
everyone knew
kind of everyone and within the black
community the west indian community
everyone knew everyone
everyone had an auntie or cousin an
uncle who knew such and such
so in a way i was kind of protected
even though i went to a predominantly
white school people knew my cousins
people knew who
were associated with my cousins so they
didn't really mess with me too much i
would get into an
odd fight here and there to prove myself
but other than that i didn't really get
picked on
and then my cousins left that high
school and then it was kind of like
okay game on yeah it was like kumite in
high school yeah
it really was especially towards the
last few years
it was education was there
but i was going for a whole rite of
passage you know
um playing footy with the boys and then
discovering art which i was really
getting into
and then discovering hip-hop and
american culture
and then discovering like
things like malcolm x and martin luther
king and the civil rights movement and
the five percent so all this stuff is
happening between the ages of like 14
and 16.
and um i started rebelling a little bit
as we all do when we get into those
teenage years and uh
after a while i i was brought up and
raised in the anglican
church of england i was an altar boy
and then 16 hit i found alcohol
i found some other vices and um
it was kind of like yeah off to the
races
and one of the things that was really
instrumental i would say in my
upbringing was
at 16 i wanted to go to art college
or art school and i was doing
comic book art and i wasn't really
serious with
art um at school i was just doing doing
my own stuff
and my teacher i remember my teacher one
day just saying like
why what are you doing what are you
doing with yourself you're hardly coming
to school you're hardly learning
what are you really going to do with
yourself because you're definitely not
going to make it enough
and that little fire my last year
it liter firing me and um the idea
that being told you can't yeah motivated
you yeah to do it
and that's why art school is kind of
more of a thing in
you know those vocational schools
especially back in the mid
uh 80s were really big in england you
know you had after school programs you
had youth programs
stuff like that you know and this was
during the time of thatcherism and
you know that big uh recession that
england had at the time
so the youth were kind of wild at that
time
and um a lot of us you know the rave
scene was really big and you were ever
into the rave scene you were either
playing footy
or you were doing art and you were
living in that ah and
in that art was when i found like you
know
guys when they hip-hop and guys who were
really culturally kind of diverse
and um i started being other than
what my parents saw me and what the
community saw me i kind of
was kind of outgrowing them so to speak
and then i was going off to london i had
a sister in london
i have two sisters and one of them lived
in london and i would go to london and
just hang out there and soak up that
culture and i'd go to museums and
go to soho and go to the record store
and
pick up vinyl and then at 16 i decided
to
leave home which was
killed my parents what was the
motivation behind that
why did you feel like you had to get out
at that time my father was a man yeah
you know i was coming into
new things i was
finding myself i was hanging out with
these kind of bohemian cats
who were already in art school and they
had known people who i'd known so i was
hanging out with them
and then funny enough i got into art
school right
in london or where did you move in
ipswich there was a really big
um art college called suffolk art
college that a lot of famous artists
came out of um in fact one of my
teachers was brian eno
for anyone who who knows who brian eno
is yeah yeah yeah well i'm just when i
when i said
that art my sense that art school is a
bigger thing in
in england than it is here i'm thinking
about all the musicians you know like
the radiohead guys like yeah you know
all these
um great artists are a product of
kind of it's a state thing though right
like it's it's not like private colleges
like no
no you could go to a private college but
most of us you know we
got on rides and you know um
i was lucky in the fact that i was
working two jobs i had worked two jobs
since i was like 13 14.
so i was making some income anyway and
then i was getting a little bit of help
on the side
so that's how i basically managed to
live kind of rent free i was squatting
with my cousin
and going to art college and working at
clowns as a dishwasher at night right so
you moved out
from your parents house but you were
still in ipswich yeah school yeah
yeah right so
yeah through 16 up until i was about 18
man i was
i was wild yeah making the scene
i was wild man um so are drugs a part of
that
um yeah yeah i was i was i was running
with a lot of cats who were dealing with
ecstasy at the time and then hash was
real big
and hatch was real big in the in the
college scene you know
in our college scene so you know we were
dealing hash we were selling house you
were selling ecstasy the whole nine
yards
good times yeah it was a wow
so how long did you do that for oh so
did you graduate up until
yeah i graduated um and i was about
17 18 and i got a phone call from my
cousin
um one of my cousins in london who i was
very very close with and she came to
ipswich to visit some family and she
came to where i was squatting
she was pissed she's like you need to
come see your parents
they got some news for you so i went to
go i'm going to go over there for sunday
dinner i hadn't been over there in
probably months we just didn't get on
so i go over there and um
they were like we got some news for you
he's like okay
what is it my cousin was the mediator at
the time
and it was a green card and they were
like
do you want to come to america with us
we're going wow
so at that time i just had i had a
couple of mates of mine
go to jail um
we had known a couple of um there was
one family
friend who had just committed suicide in
jail who we knew
um a whole bunch of mates and men were
really getting into the whole ecstasy
thing and dealing and
yeah it was like the future is looking
bleak if you don't
make a change and um
at the time i was looking at unis
universities to
carry on art and
but i i had to weigh my options and at
that time i was really enamored by
hip-hop i was so enamored by hip-hop
like you know watching your mtv raps
watching firefight freddy
um i had an american uncle who was on
the air force base so it was
i love comic books hot dogs the whole
nine yards right the whole american
culture
so i was like okay let's give it a shot
brooklyn there you go it's not like it's
not like they were
moving to st louis or something right
like brooklyn
like it's happening there yeah right
yeah so you're and you're
you're thinking you're a grown man but
you're 17. oh right yeah i was 17 just
turned
turning 18. uh-huh and i was not a man
i was not a man because i got thrusted
into brooklyn and
and meanwhile i want to preface it i had
gone to brooklyn like
every other summer it was a it was a
thing for my family
to kind of send you over it's already
kind of new
i was raised in brooklyn so to speak it
was like a second home to me
um i remember buying my first big daddy
cane album on flatbush avenue
i remember buying my first pair of fat
laces and some adidas shell toes
you know what i mean so i knew flatbush
but this was during the crack era
this was like 91. this was
big like jamaican posses were running
flat bush
so i get the flat bush and it wasn't the
flatbush that i knew
and i had an uncle who
had worked for the world trade center at
the time he was a security guard
and i had two aunts and two cousins who
lived in this brownstone
and um i lived there
for about half a year mm-hmm and um
originally back into school in brooklyn
well that was the thing i had originally
planned on going to pratt or f.i.t
but i just got jaded when i was there it
was just
not how i envisioned it it was fast
paced it was not
new york how you know
[Music]
so i had my father's sister lived in
austin texas
and i was really close because those
were the cousins that were my protectors
in high school
yeah and um i remember having a
conversation with my aunt and she was
like do you want to move to austin
maybe it'll be a little bit easier for
you here so new york brooklyn
overwhelming overwhelming now let's keep
in mind i ended up coming back to
brooklyn a little bit later
as i got older and that was like
a right to passage for me but we'll come
back to that
um so i moved to austin texas
and lived in austin from
92 all the way up until about 98
and that was that's another chapter in
my life
yeah so what was going on there
you fell into like the south by
southwest yes yes
yes so um after kind of establishing
myself
and kind of making new friends and
i had a lot of friends who were going to
ut the university of texas
getting enamored in texas culture
learning about texas relays
um you know the the mexican culture
within texas
cowboy culture it was because to be
honest with you
it's strange oh well to be honest with
you you've got to remember this boy from
ipswich
and and all i could think about with
texas was dallas
that's all i knew about was dallas not
even a football team just dallas the
the tv show jr yep
and there was there was no black folks
on there so i'm thinking to myself
definitely and i'm thinking about john
wayne and i'm thinking about everything
texas and i'm like it's amazing you even
went
if that's all you knew you know i've had
this love-hate relationship with being
in uncomfortable situations
and i've just trusted myself in them
and this was one of them but it ended up
being
such a jewel in the rough
because coming to austin
was where i truly learned about veganism
vegetarianism kung fu
the eastern martial arts herbs
um this everything you could think of
was all in my growth in that span of
time of being in austin texas
um and in that time you know i moved to
america before my parents and my parents
ended up coming to new york
and then they ended up coming to austin
staying in austin
and then leaving austin to go to florida
because
um you know in that time of living in
austin
it was really hard for my parents west
indian
um my dad doesn't really have too much
of a scholastic background i mean
basically got told he
was to become a man when he was 14 years
old
and i mean there was just not really
much work for him
yeah he worked on a in a plastic
uh warehouse and then he ended up
getting laid off
so my mom ended up becoming the bread
winner and then
her dilemma was that she would have to
go back to school
so you know luckily they had their
pensions from england
but it was really really rough for them
yeah
and i would suspect i mean getting your
green card there's all this promise the
american dream we're going to go to
america and we're going to stake our
claim and we're going to have this life
and then to be met with resistance and
frustration oh it was
yeah i mean they've already suffered it
from england and luckily they were able
to build up and establish themselves
but then to come here and to start from
square one again and come from the route
i mean
and i know my my mom is going to watch
this and be like why are you telling the
story but i have to
um i remember
being god maybe in 1920 and i know we
were supposed to talk about south by
southwest but we'll come back all right
man we got time
all day um i remember one time
her having you know this trouble
getting into the nursing system and you
know she was doing some
work going to people's houses and
helping elderly
but it was doing a number on her back
and she already had back issues already
and something happened and she ended up
taking another job and it ended up being
mcdonald's
and i just remembered those times
of her having to navigate
working helping elderly
breaking her back my father's not
working
i think i was working like circuit city
or something like that i wasn't really
making that much money
and she was had a brand new house
earning little to nothing and i just
remembered her working these two jobs
and being like
[ __ ] this is really something and i
really need to do something in my life
because it was really tearing me apart
at that time
like my parent my mum was basically
looking after me and my father
so you know seeing that that really had
a profound effect on me and i was like
okay i need to really start doing
something with myself
so as i said i was working with circus
city and then i ended up working for ups
and in that time i was in a
music group with these three guys we
were called
sockeye i think that was my first
hip-hop group
and we met i can't remember how we met
but we met
and then something happened with one of
the guys from the group
and we were like on the cusp of like
really doing big things we were working
with these guys named mad flavor out of
dallas
who subsequently ended up
becoming uh um
tied up with erica free who later ended
up becoming erica bardu
but that's another story but looking
into your story poking around the
internet there's some music out there
oh yeah it is a little bit like what is
this
i didn't know about this one yeah
there's a there's a there's a little bit
so ended up doing this thing we ended up
calling ourselves x factor
become really um become kind of
you know godfathers in in hip-hop in
austin
i mean what was the what's that what was
the hip-hop scene in austin at the time
i mean
at that time there was a guy named dj
castanova who was at this place called
catfish
station and there was like um overlord x
who was a very well-known guy but it
wasn't
really breaking ground like
it should be or it should have
so obviously me being who i am
i come to austin and then i started
befriending these guys
in this skate shop called blondies
they're in this place called barton's
greek where or square mall
and i go in there and i'm like hey do
you have the philly blunt t-shirt that
was the rage back in new york in the day
and they were like no
and i was like well you should really
get into that and then from there spend
a relationship and i would hip him to
stuff and they would bring stuff in
they ended up moving out the mall and
moving on this place called
um guadalupe guadalupe strip which is
right by
ut it's the hub of where everything is
um and you're the guy who's telling him
what's what yeah right
okay so then i form a friendship with a
guy in tower records
and he's handing me stuff like that's
like
new and upcoming and i'm getting all lee
so i'm becoming like a street promoter
so then i start street promotion for
like certain labels like loud records
big beat um several different hip hop
def jam that led to me
starting bringing groups into austin
texas
then i started working at this club
called emos
emos is a um at the time was a very
punk rock venue and it was where
everyone was going like um
gizzy from the butthole surfers used to
hang out there
right the reverend horton heat would
hang out there like the 9 30 club of
austin
yes exactly so everyone was hanging out
there
i mean to this day there were so many
people who i met
like danzig i would work um
like neo-nazi right like
yes punk dudes right so
i had formed a relationship with this
guy named chris thomannago aka sweetener
and me and him ended up becoming really
good friends and he was the promoter
and then there was a guy named dave and
then there was emo
and um i had formed a relationship with
these guys and then these guys knew that
i was in hip-hop circle and running with
these skate guys
and from there we all formed the
relationship and we're like
they're south by southwest but south by
southwest is predominantly white it's
predominantly cowboys and
you know uh you know all this other type
of music
yeah alt rock exactly let's get some
hip-hop in there
and we formed up and when
people didn't want to house hip-hop
because they thought it was going to be
too rough
they thought there was going to be gang
activities we were like
well let's bring it to the punk scene
you can't get no more punk than hip-hop
[Music]
and the punk scene embraced it and from
there um you know
one of the guys who was booking shows
there was a guy named dave who worked
for south by southwest
and then i knew this guy named andre who
i managed to bring them to together and
thus that created kind of
the the genesis of what we kind of see
in hip-hop
and south by southwest today because at
that time no one really wanted to take a
chance on hip-hop
but it was a there's a few guys who were
like no [ __ ] that we're gonna
we're gonna make a scene and we'll do it
through the punk way
and then not only did the punk boys
really love it the skateboards really
loved it
and then through there i met these two
dudes
um that became
my guise in bringing
hip-hop groups to austin now here's the
caveat
they were ecstasy dealers and they had
relationships with all the strippers in
town
and that's how they made all their money
i'm putting them on blast now
they're gonna they're gonna laugh
because they're gonna know the story but
i ran with these cats who were just
they were ahead of their time as far as
like the
you know um marijuana and ecstasy
they were getting kind burden and all is
good but when it was just like dirt swag
in
in in austin yeah so i'm running with
these dudes and these dudes were
basically like
you will pay you to bring these hip-hop
dudes into town
and let's make big shows
and we did it and then that caught the
eye of south by southwest
and they were like okay you have the
power to bring these big groups in
let's make a showcase and i remember one
of the
first showcases that was really big was
95 96
where we brought rizza and at the time
that was when rizzo had grave diggers
uh gravediggers came through exhibit big
pun
uh i remember doing one of our first
shows with the roots
um when they were first coming out and
then that just grew
and then the next thing you know austin
became a hub
for not only old rock country
um you know all different types of
rave music it was really becoming a hub
and then south by southwest grew and it
grew
and by time i left it became like a mega
machine
what's interesting about that is that
you could have i mean you were having
success you could have just doubled down
on that
groove that lo that lane that you'd
establish for yourself and become
you know like the the king of that scene
in austin
well this is where the next story comes
yeah so
in that time of partying and
smoking copious amounts of weed and um
you know just i was living kind of a
crazy lifestyle because i was working
circuit city i was working ups so i was
working
all different types of hours i had an
amazing girlfriend at the time who is
still working in circuit city yeah i'm
stealing all this oh yeah
yeah still doing all this stuff right
had an amazing girlfriend who was a
photographer at the time her name was
alexa
um and she was like in the hip-hop scene
also
and you know it was just a part of the
scene
but then what had happened was because
of all this partying
because of all the successive back and
forth
um i got really and
um that's what kind of led to
me finding vegetarianism
so i met this guy named etienne at ups
who was like the super yogi at the time
and um hopefully he gets a chance to
listen to this because i owe him
a lot this guy was ahead of his time he
was
a sproutarian he was the guy that hit me
and i know you know this book
really well um uh the guy to the 21st
century
victor convince kiss and dick gregory
you remember that book yeah yeah
so that was my that was my hebrew he
basically gave me that book
and i remember one time walking out of
work and he was like
hawk your belly is just out of control
you got to do something brother
and this one up too yeah you were
getting fatter oh yeah i was like 260
270 pounds i was like
greasy like z the whole nine yards that
was just like
a mess and um he was like bro you need
to change you got to change
and no sooner than he said that about
two months later i was
lying in bed bleeding out of every
orifice out of my body
and i was like i need to do something
and at that time there's a paper called
austin chronicle
and on the back there was
a acupuncturist free acupuncture session
and in that same week
i had gone to the chinese restaurant
right down the street from my house
and found a card for kung fu
and the guy who practiced kung fu lived
a block away from me
so all these things were coming into
play this confluence of
events the universe is signaling the
universe is signaling right
and i love the fact that like the the
original guru
mentor is this sprouting ups guy yeah
it's almost like out of a dan millman
book
or something yeah truly truly i came
he was he was uh he was a rastafarian
who was
um a sportarian
uh a connoisseur of herbology he knew
all the things go to cola dandelion the
whole nine yards and
break it down yeah exactly
exactly right so keep in mind i was
i was a sunny muslim at the time um
that had kind of flirted with nation
islam and
and and five percent and then i meet
this roster
and then i totally just go through this
i give up alcohol i
start doing master cleanses
and then i before that i go to this
acupuncturist
and this keep in mind i had been having
irritable bowel syndrome
um i was having heartburn
uh everything for for the previous like
two years i would say two and two to two
and a half years but it came to a head
so when i came to this acupuncturist i
took stool samples no i was a guinea pig
for zantac
no one really isolated the issue
within five minutes of me being with
this acupuncturist
he was like you have busted your
iliosecular valve
you have major ulcers and if you don't
change your life i'm going to give you
seven
eight years tops
you're talking to a 21 year old yeah and
he was like i'm going to give you seven
to eight years tops
wow you have diabetes that runs in your
family you have high blood pressure that
runs in your family you have all this
stuff that runs in your family
if you don't change your ways
you're not gonna be around and you are
able to hear that
this cat was this white boy buddhist who
is about to go to china
to to convert to become a full buddhist
and i was one of his last
sessions before he went to go wow
and you kind of skirted over it quickly
but i think it bears
you know taking a minute to
talk about the fact that behind all of
this
you've always been a spiritual seeker
right like you're a race christian
yeah then you just mentioned that you
know you were you're muslim
you've had these various incarnations
where you've dropped in
on these you know a wide variety of
different
dogmatic religious approaches to to life
so
that was always there right yeah
so what is that seeking sensibility all
about and where do you think that comes
from
um i wasn't satisfied with christianity
for one stop
that was this i was you you weren't down
with the church no
i was not me and i love you mom
but you forced me to
i would lie to you you know hardcore
jamaican parents that are like
you know i wasn't when when i said i
wasn't
baptized i was like get in there
so you know then the other but then you
have the rasta guy oh man
different flavor of it was jamaican yeah
but then
let's and then you had islam too right
so
the islam piece was really deep because
um you know sunny
being sunny in england and then coming
over here and then being immersed in
black
nationalists that black nationalist
movement
and the nation and then the five percent
nation that was really radical at the
time
the bow tie fairy yeah and then you know
you had like the the brand nubians and
the
you know the poor righteous teachers and
you know all
along the hip-hop circles but it was
just a form of
for me it was a form of me finding
myself because you can remember i got
raised in all white england i had black
family and black community but i was
really never
part of a movement my father was
my father got to see the hands worth
rides and the you know the brixton riots
and the tottenham right so he was part
of that but i wasn't
so then coming to the states
and and seeing the plight of
black americans and black culture on a
whole
um i identified with it so
and then the rel the the the kind of
religious connotation or the spiritual
connotation
through islam it taught me a sense of
discipline
through the five percent nation it
taught me a sense of knowledge and to
study
and many people go to schools of
theology to study all these major
religions and
i studied this myself
[Music]
no one told me to go pick up the torah
or to go pick up the quran
or go pick up the bible it was a five
percenter
named true power allah who was like
you know study empire strikes back study
return of the jedi study
the peaceful warrior study the dao de
jing
study all these books and a
differentiator also being that
distinct from just esoteric kind of
theological ideas this was very much a
get your [ __ ] together
and yes you know what kind of man do you
want to be in the world
yes which you needed yes yes
so all of that so when you say when you
when you ask about seeking
i was seeking myself out i was really
seeking myself
out but seeking how to become the person
that i'm i am today i didn't know it
back then
because i was still dipping my toes in
the spiritual world but still
being a householder and still trying to
do all the things that were
cool and still hit but also a
willingness to
continue to iterate and and grow right
like
you know when something stops serving
you or you see a new idea you're
you you strike me as somebody who's
always open to that as opposed to just
becoming entrenched in one
way yeah that that's a that's a i think
that's a big aquarian thing
i i get that a lot i i from other
aquarians or people
are you an aquarium because we have this
innate ability here
yes exactly to seek it so
i'm not just resting on the fact okay
kung fu's cool praying madness is cool i
wanted to go deeper
and that's when i went into the tai chi
and that's when i went into you know the
taoism
and you know the rust
the rastafari was amazing because
rastafari
really taught me how to eat
how to look after my body how to look
after my temple
that was such a great component and and
meeting etienne
and who was this character who was doing
africa
african angolan capoeira and
capoeira is cool oh yeah yeah so you got
these cats there was a crew
right there was a crew of cats i had my
crew that were kung fu
i had the crew that was angola capoeira
and
we were doing music but we weren't of
that lifestyle anymore
so i had kind of renounced you know a
lot of people like kind of
shut a lot of people out yeah and all
that stuff it wasn't me anymore
to the point where a lot of people when
i came back into the scene
they were like are you on crack because
i had lost a hundred and something
pounds
i now had locks i had this big old beard
and i'm talking about doing fast for
like
20 days right i'm talking about being a
sproutarian
and a fruitarian and you know doing
wheatgrass shots
when i used to do shots of jaeger and
and
you know what other shots so it was um
it was a deep deep time and and in that
time i found kung fu
um there was a woman who uh who owned um
an herb store in town and she took me
under her wing
and i tore my meniscus and i kind of did
it you know healed it myself and i would
go to the herb store she would give me
herbs to rebuild
my knee um i started going to the
bookstore and studying yoga
and i had books of yoga so i
started doing yoga myself and then
lo and behold i found tai chi and my
teacher
sifu hughes who is an amazing teacher if
you're ever in austin you want to learn
about kung fu or tai chi he's the guy
along with my brother thomas leverett um
these guys were instrumental
in me finding tai chi
um finding the eastern arts
and there was a time when the the my
girlfriend broke up
and then i had this house to myself and
this house became
the dojo it became where everyone came
and i had a futon
a seat my records
uh kung fu movies out to yahoo
at the yin yang and a pull-up bar and a
bed
and that was it and all the homies came
over and we would read
we would drink tea and we would study
that's crazy man this was back in like
uh-huh so it starts with kung fu and
acupuncture basically but then you kind
of blossom from there
yeah so what is it that you're learning
specifically
in kung fu and this introduction to
chinese medicine that gives you a sense
of belonging and direction
it was this it was like an aha moment it
was like
because i was so enamored with kung fu
right and and obviously
at that time you know wu-tang was really
big
and they were talking about it and then
you had cats like jeru
and then you had um you had other cats
that were coming in the scene so there
was a lot of you know again hip-hop is
closely tied to a lot of
the stuff that was going on and i'm
looking at the the landscape and i was
like
wow there's a lot of black folks that
are doing different
things and entering different spaces and
not so much cultural appropriation but
really acknowledging
the east and how you know that silk road
came from
africa or you know and through china and
they were very
closely connected so i started seeing
that there was a very
close synergy between african culture
and and eastern culture and i really
started delving into it and
and i just knew how much um
at the time there was a real big shiatsu
school in austin
and my friends uh thomas and claudia
uh became chef sir they they went
through the macrobiotic school of
training and i became
really um i saw the power of
macrobiotics and i was like wow this is
amazing
and then um with kung fu
and you know learning how to make your
own remedies
and you know dijo is a special
concoction that
a lot of martial arts use whenever they
bruise themselves you know sandbag
training metal training
you rub this ointment and it heals you
space from taoist law
and it's been passed down through
generation to generations
so learning stuff like this and learning
the herbal culture and then
you know adding all this knowledge that
i'm seeing i'm like
this is something so then as i said
me and my girl break up my mom and dad
are in orlando
and i'm like you know what they're
getting older and i don't want to be in
the same town i don't want to be in the
same city as this woman
and i have a lot of history here
let me go and be with my parents and go
study
chinese medicine study eastern
philosophy yada yada
and originally i was going to go to
acupuncture school but i was not making
enough money
um even still working still working in
ups and circus yeah
but the bands the bands weren't you were
doing that because i was kind of
at that point i was still fragilizing
with music
but um
i didn't really feel it like that
anymore
it wasn't doing it for me what was doing
it for me was
learning about the arts learning about
you know because i really wanted to
become an acupuncturist i really wanted
to
be on some matulou shakur type
business and friend for all people out
there who don't know mature shakur
was part of the black nationalist
movement in the 60s and i want to say he
was
tupac's uncle
um he was one of the first
acupuncturists
black acupuncturists in the states oh
wow
um and was real revolutionary for
bringing
um acupuncture to the hood
so i was in i was so enamored by that
story i was like
this is this is
this is you know not the purview of
you know the black man in america right
right i mean it sounds like you were
creating your own scene
yeah and it's interesting how you know
music is sort of a catalyst for this
like when you're
recounting your story i'm thinking about
hr from bad brains and you know kind of
the impact that he has had in a similar
way to his music and advocacy and how
many lives he was able to touch and
change
you're having a kind of analogous
experience to that
but there aren't a lot of examples of
black men who are pursuing a path like
this yeah
not a lot and funny enough
sidebar i used to hang with hr's road
manager
in austin texas oh wow way back in the
day
so that's my connection to hr
funny enough yeah did you ever come
across john joseph from the crowmag
no and it's funny because we all know
kind of the same
circles um but john's story is similar
to yours
yeah i mean hr took him in and sorted
him out and you know he went
down his own you know wellness rabbit
yeah that's kind of similar to yours
yeah
yeah i've got a feeling we're going to
meet each other very soon so
and and we also have a very mutual
friend um
and hopefully the ancestors are looking
after him as we speak david clarke who
transitioned oh right you knew yeah yeah
yeah
that was a very good home of mine so um
but anyway so with all that being said
i was really enamored by um
you know matulish corp and and and funny
enough in orlando i ended up
befriending his first student
that ended up adopting the program wow
was that random or did you know who's
random was there it was random
so yeah so he's like i'm going to go to
orlando the hotbed
like acupuncture it was and culture
it was so surreal how we met and this
was later down the road and i ended up
having him really her name was dr akira
zula
um amazing woman she was one of dr
mathila shakur's very first students
and practiced acupuncture i don't know
if it was i want to say it was harlem
but her and dr shakur
practice acupuncture for free
in harlem when acupuncture was not
looked at
in a very good light especially with
black bodies doing it yeah so
to have her in i've met a lot of
and been taught and been brought under
new england after
under a lot of people she's definitely
one of the people that i
i hold in high regard because she was
able to
share stories with me of those days
and how hard it was for black bodies
not only to um bring
acupuncture to a level of prominence
but to show and prove why it was
effective and
show and prove why it was effective to
black folk who definitely weren't
looking at acupuncture
so um you know
having her and meeting her was amazing
and instrumental in my life but
um at that time i wanted to be an
acupuncturist and i was
i didn't make enough money um so i saw a
program
that was at this massage school that was
all eastern body work
they taught shiatsu they taught tuina
they taught five element theory
and they taught tai chi and i was like
i'm going to that school so that's what
she did so that's what i did
yeah and i moved to orlando and i moved
in with my parents
for the um thief time i've moved to my
parents so many times
but how old are you now like 25 or
something yeah i'm like 25 26.
it's not like you're you know 42 years
old or something
but um so i ended up moving in with them
and um yeah i went to college and then
this guy
dr sean oldham took me under his wing
and for that it was a speed program
which they don't do anymore but it was
like a six month
every day and night program you learned
was it 200 or 500 hours of massage and
then x amount of hours in
traditional chinese medicine theory yada
yada
i had some amazing teachers but this
teacher this guy was amazing in the fact
that
he was buddhist and he was my first
vegan
that lived a monk life but that was a
householder
that really lived it lived it lived it
[Music]
and um yeah i studied with him
right before he moved to north carolina
he got a practice in north carolina at
the time he was one of the world's
leading pediatric acupuncturists
where he was just like working on kids
with major major problems and he was
world renowned
and um he taught me tai chi he taught me
uh so much about five element theory
taught me so much about acupuncture
acupressure
and then um taught me this other form of
martial arts called bagua
so i got immersed into the internal
martial arts world
where i just became immersed and in that
time
um i
kind of found music again and i had met
some guys who lived right down the
street from
the the the the um massage school
and um then i started working on my
first album along with going to massage
school wow
well chinese medicine's no joke my i
mean
people spend decades yeah immersed in
that
trying to get a handle on it my buddy
colin went to the i don't know in the
name of the school here in los angeles
he's a doctor of chinese medicine now
but i mean it was like he went to
medical school
it is you know very very intense and
then i would go and get
acupuncture with him because as a
practicing student i could get it for
cheap
nothing yeah exactly but then the the
the kind of
mentor uh you know full chinese doctor
would come in
and oversee it yeah and then he would do
the thing where he takes your pulse
the pulse you know and they're like
these masters of
touch and feeling where like a hundred
ways over
50 years he's been doing this and they
can tell you everything about your
health from putting their thumb on you
yeah isn't that amazing and then you get
some wacky herbs
you know exactly way out bro i can tell
you some stories
i can tell you some stories like the one
time
when i had finished massage school i
don't know if it was
it was so weird i had these lesions
on my arms that this came out of nowhere
and i don't know if it was stress
or what um
[Music]
but it was traditional chinese medicine
and i remember
being in a bath
of different wacky herbs covering these
lesions
but it worked yeah i don't know what it
was but it worked and those guys that
can
can uh you know do the pulse thing
they're wizards
they are absolutely amazing and there's
you know as i said there's like over a
hundred ways of
reading pulses and they can tell you
basically
they can tell you oh you were eating too
much dairy when you were like five years
old
right i know and you're like come on man
yeah where's the scam yeah where's the
scam and and like this dude as i said
you know the dude who i went
when i first initially went through my
stuff
doctors had been trying to figure out
what was going on and didn't know what
was going on within five minutes
he knew exactly what was going on so
does anybody at some point say
come on man like pick your thing is it
going to be kung fu or tai chi or
massage or
acupuncture i was your weirdo you're
exposing yourself to
you know so many different traditions
like how does that all
synthesize and synergize like do you
have and and
and on top of that all these different
kind of philosophical spiritual
religious you know notions are swimming
around in your head like you're like a
mishmash of everything right like yeah
does this
does this congeal into some kind of
universal theory
how does that work you know it was so at
that time i didn't really even know what
i was doing i was just
in it just living life you know
again i come back to it you know
coming from ipswich there's not really
it's like coming from like
buffalo somewhere outside of texas or
you know it's a small town you know
there's
there's stuff happening but who would
have thunk that i would have thought
about
acupuncture and i would be immersed in
rastafarianism
and five percent and eating frigging
sprouts learning how to do my own
you know broccoli broccoli sprouts in my
cupboard you know i mean
um but at that time
i was just more like what can i do
[Music]
how can i be a game changer how can i
make lanes for myself
and that's why i really got into the
eastern
philosophy and the eastern arts because
there wasn't a lot of black bodies doing
it
um and i was really enamored by that and
i saw that there was a spiritual
connotation
to africa and to the motherland
so i was able to you know with the
knowledge that i had i was able to come
back and be like okay well this comes
back to this and this
relates to this so there was that
and then
you got to remember i was really sick
and
all of these things that i learned were
healing arts
and then on top of that there was a
period of time when i was a rough
cat and i was beating people up and i
was like
you know slapping people for fun and it
was
that's not me so coming
to the healing side was really
grounding and was really fortifying for
me
and then the knowledge
you know was this i felt like it was
just making me a better person
so the more i seek them the more i'd
learned the more i could just like
help more people out and because i
realized i had seen where i was and and
and the all help and all the guides and
all the people
that helped me get my way not only could
i be a game changer
i can actually help people being a game
changer yeah
so my thing was i i wanted to be
different i wanted to be different i
didn't want to be
just oh this guy from england who came
over and is this
you know lost in a shuffle i wanted to
be
somebody who is going to make a name for
myself and i didn't know to what
capacity
and my parents will always say to you
you know he always wanted to be
something
i wanted but it was i just knew
and especially from that time seeing my
parents how hard they worked
how hard and diligent they've done
in their life i wanted somehow to pay it
back to them and they wanted to go
through the steps
to show that i'm working hard to get
there but to show that i can make it
and somehow pay it forward sooner or
later the path wasn't
uh you know go to medical school or go
to law school
yeah you had to go on this crazy inward
aquarium
journey to find yourself and become an
integrated
you know human being yeah and it's it's
what's cool about it is how
heartfelt and organic it is it's not
like oh here's
here's what i'm going to do and it's
going to get me to this place like
it was just a like a relentless pursuit
of you know personal growth and whatever
flavor you could find it and you had
this thirst for it
and that all kind of like sated you and
got you to this place where you could be
of service
yeah but that idea that behind it all
you you had
some knowledge or understanding that
this was going to lead you
in the direction you were meant to go
most definitely
yeah most definitely so you're
scrambling though like you can't be
you can't be you know making more than
minimum wage
there's a stereotype of you know the
west indian man or
that dude who worked like four or five
jobs and i was that dude right
i literally was that dude i was working
like four or five jobs
i was teaching massage because at this
time now
i had graduated and the the guy at the
school
um loved me i got on really well with
all the teachers
so they brought me in to teach what dr
sean oldham
taught which was five element theory
because you know i was under his wing
so then i started teaching tai chi
so then that led to um
you know me making a name for myself
within the city
with tai chi and um
i started learning with several
different teachers
sifu kent howard who was a bhagwa
specialist
um this guy uh sifu lowly who was a wu
stylist who was a wushu
stylist and then i met
wang sifu and wang sifu
was an old guy from shanghai
who no one knew about you had to
basically
know somebody who knew him in order to
learn with him
and wang sifu taught on a
rooftop in downtown orlando
so i knew this guy named paul who we
did some martial arts together and he
was like oh
um you're really into tai chi you need
to see
this guy but you're going to have to
come to a couple of classes because he's
not going to just
let you in uh-huh he's like the miyagi
wizard yeah yeah get permission
so in a very cinematic on a rooftop
it really was it really was and you know
for any martial artists out there you
know there is a certain
thing that is called the indoor circle
or indoor society
and it's basically when you get to a
certain stature in your
martial arts practice where you get
invited
into certain sex they have it in our
niece where they
you know or the filipino martial arts
they have it in the japanese martial
arts where it's closed off you can
only get initiated you just you get a
tap on the shoulder one day basically
yeah and this was my tap in the shoulder
and um
that was really another chapter because
at that time there was a place called
garden cafe in orlando
that was a restaurant that was ran by
daois
real legit that was monks so
at that time um they had known that i
did tai chi
and know that i was immersed in the arts
and they were like
come to the holy house come see
what we're all about so then that
started me down a rabbit hole of taoism
and i was initiated in this holy house
in this taoist sect while doing tai chi
so you know religious spiritual vertigo
oh my god
so i mean i told you i got some stories
right
so in this time i'm learning tai chi
um with this tai chi teacher on a
rooftop
learning four or five i would go see him
twice a week tuesdays on thursdays and
we'd study for four or five hours
end up drinking chinese rum
reading chinese newspapers um paul would
smoke chinese cigarettes and we were
just immersed
in this life and then i had taoism
so you know
taoism you're just getting it from all
sorts of or all angles and i'm still
i'm still messing with the rosters in
orlando because i still got my locks
yada yada
so i'm still you know i'm still with
everyone yada yada
so um i i meet this girl who
i ended up marrying and um
and then my life takes a different
course man you know
chapter 11. yeah
[Laughter]
my life takes a different course and
then i get married uh
while we date and soon enough
i have my first child mm-hmm um it was a
very
it it was a whirlwind romance
that got very serious very quick
[Music]
and um you know the caveat
was it was a white girl and um
you know a lot of the a lot of the
community didn't feel it
and you know i was a bit i was kind of
blackballed in
in you know the kind of afro-spiritual
community that i was in
oh wow that's interesting yeah it was it
was it was a really it was a really deep
time
and um yeah i had my first
kid at the same time i had just
put out my first album uh-huh and what
are you 27 or something
like 28. no no at this time i'm like
just turned 30.
very faint one and um the music is going
really well and um
you know i'm starting to make moves we
start talking about tour and then my
goal is like
put that [ __ ] on hold me that ain't
happening
and you know um i have i have a great
relationship with my ex-wife now but
married being having a kid not knowing
that person and not
really really solidifying a relationship
like you supposed to
was rough so having my first child i
learned
the rough way of fatherhood um
and then you know uh god
my first child is 16 so then four years
later we have another one
um two daughters two daughters and then
she got real
and all the spiritual practice and all
the tai chi was still there and i was
still doing the tai chi but
the spiritual practice and everything
kind of went away
and i really started getting into
householder lifestyle and
you know my
wife at the time was very traditional in
the aspect like
you're going to work you're going to be
the breadwinner i'm going to stay at
home and look after the kids
[Music]
and you know just seeing how my my
parents were i was like okay
that's that's this is what i signed up
for
and you know the one thing about having
kids that i always
envisioned was that kid is always going
to be around me no matter what
then i have two i'm working three jobs
i'm working whole foods at the time
um massage envy
because i'm and i'm teaching so i'm
teaching i'm massaging
i'm working whole foods but no more
five-hour
rooftop get-togethers uh that kind of
yeah came to hop it was like no you you
gotta be a father
so um you know
becoming a father becoming a householder
and you know not
no knock on my my ex but she was not
spiritual
she was a atheist and
you know having being kind of
blackballed from a certain community and
then having a wife that was not
spiritual where am i now
[Music]
yeah identity crisis big time big time
so you know um life happened
um i this became
you know the guy who was the white
picket fence man
right we had dogs we had the minivan
i was working three jobs that was my
life
and you know i i i remember one time
you know i had all these dreams and
aspirations of going to ethiopia going
to mexico going to
costa rica and had all these dreams and
aspirations of doing all this stuff
you know teaching tai chi or you know
um teaching time some type of spiritual
what have you right all that [ __ ] went
away now my life is relegated to
becoming a householder
just becoming you know the pictures of
ganesha the pictures of buddha the
pictures of malcolm x the pictures
all of those things were going out the
house
it was toys everywhere
so in our last house before the big d
i had a room right so what i didn't
talk about was i have a big vinyl
collection like a monumental vinyl
collection
right and then i have a pretty big book
that has spanned with me all the way
from ipswich
all the way to brooklyn all the way to
austin has traveled with me everywhere
so i had this room that was literally
like my record room and it was literally
like my sanctuary i put all my spiritual
stuff everything it was like a little
room
in this big old mansion that we used to
live in and um
yeah these things just went from bad to
worse and
we just fell out of love and my next kid
came i had a
i had one more child named layla
and so i have naya isla and layla
and um leila came and laila came
with a broken hip out of the womb
so that was there's a lot going on
right that's a lot so you know we're
having to take her to john hopkins and
she's having to get her she's having to
be in the cast up until
nine months old so you know i'm
we're looking after two kids taking them
to school yadda yadda and then we have
this one here so keep in mind my
my ex was a triathlete
up until we met then we had kids
she put on weight and then she
rediscovered the gym again
lost all the weight and became this
badass
like gym rat which was
detrimental
you don't have that privilege you got it
you knocked it right on the head
right so there's so much stuff going on
she's going to the gym every day
i'm here they're going on disney cruises
the kids are all going on disney cruises
you know they're living the best life
they got the best life they're they they
have no
idea you know we got a big trampoline
my parents are paying for you know my
parents did so much because they knew i
was
only one person so they were paying for
groceries they would like
you know we don't want you to just you
know we know it's a lot
i'm paying for two cars a minivan you
know the whole nine yards
and you got three jobs going three jobs
gone
so you know i'm i'm resentful
so in that time i
started seeing running
and i don't know how the conversation
occurred i was starting to lose weight
because she was losing weight
and i might put the weight back on i put
it it was kind of fluctuating back and
forth right throughout the years
it fluctuated so at this time i was
about 220
to about 220 215 220. tai chi is not
keeping the weight
he's not keeping the weight off so i get
my jump rope
i used to love jump roping so i get a
jump rope out and then
discover kettlebells so i'm doing
kettlebells this was before crossfit
became real big
the homie thomas who is my kung fu
brother ended up becoming one of the
first guys to do crossfit in texas
so he told me about the kettlebell so i
was enamored with kettlebells and i
started doing kettlebells
jump rope and um but i needed it
to cut it a little bit more so she told
me about running
because she shredded right now she's
shredded and she used to be a triathlete
she did a iron man right before my first
one
you know right so she was like yeah you
should try running
um so maybe that's something you guys
could do together
well we did and then that that didn't
work that didn't work
that didn't work that didn't work um
so then i got into barefoot running
right because when i get into something
i go into it full hog and i'm looking at
the spiritual aspect
so then that was when the vibrams were a
big thing so i get in the vibrams i get
into the barefoot running i'm studying
the kenyan running and yada yada yada
then [ __ ] hits the fan people
are dying i had within the space of like
two three years
ten people died my marriage is going to
[ __ ]
um and ultimately
the marriage is done in that time i lose
the house
i lose my kids i lost that life
um some [ __ ] happened at the end
and here i am
[Music]
with basically meeting yourself yeah
this is great this is dismantling
yeah this is your this is your
uh what my wife would call your divine
moment
yes yes and i know you've been
you've been there you i mean a version
of that yeah you know i think
i i think it's very relatable i think
you know a lot of people if not most
people have some version of this
happen in their life in retrospect
i'm sure you look back on it now with
gratitude
as a cat so much everything so much that
has happened to you since but
when it's happening i mean it's i can't
imagine anything more painful like your
whole life getting pulled out from
underneath you the the levels
you know and it's funny because i just
watched the podcast with you
and i can't remember the guy's name but
you talk about old stories right
and how to rewrite to make new
i look at all these things in the past
of where i've come from and what i've
done and
you know i was joking uh before coming
in here
and i was like you know how did i even
get into retro podcast i don't have a
story
you have an amazing story i'm like i'm
not worthy
but now after kind of listening to her
i'm like okay you do have a little bit
of a story and i'll tell you this like
as fun as it is
to have you know erin brockovich and
edward norton and all these really cool
people come in here
i have to say like my favorite part of
this job
is finding people like yourself
who i mean you have a profile and people
know who you are it's not like you're
anonymous i mean you're a public figure
on some level um but to be able to put a
microphone in front of you who has such
a worthy story and so much wisdom
and try to amplify that it gives me you
know that's like
that's the stuff man so for me this is
like the sweet spot
of the podcast and i'm grateful to have
you here because i think you have an
amazing story and so much wisdom to
share
thank you thank you i'm on it rich
honestly and that place of just being
broken and lost and confused
you know despite having this incredible
background and education and all these
various spiritual
you know techniques and traditions and
feeling
inept or unable to leverage that for
your own personal well-being and that
moment i think speaks to
how hard all of this is yeah you know
even though you knew all that stuff
you're still suffering yeah yeah and
and you know that's that's going to be
in chapter
50 because that's a what you said there
is so
beautiful um and it's so
reminiscent of my life and and and even
up till
last week even with conrad and even
the same sentiment still came into play
there's so much beauty in suffering
there's so much beauty and suffering and
i and i know it sounds
so it's not cliche
but it's people are like scratching
their head how can you
suffer how can there be beauty and
suffering
when you go through the suffering that
a lot of us have that have been on the
show that have become successful
is because when you go through that
suffering you go through such a darkness
you go through such a
bottom feeder kind of exposure
that you
learn to have gratitude for
the smallest thing
the smallest thing and when i
when i think about um
the times when
i didn't think that i was gonna
really make it out of that space
there were times rich when
i would be in the car park of whole
foods
like crying
crying my heart out screaming at the top
of my lungs looking around
like how the [ __ ] did i end up in this
situation
one of the stories that i always tell
people and it's it's a it's a story
um but it's a story that i i often tell
people because mental health and suicide
is so big
and and and and i know in this day and
age
it's being amplified and people are
talking about it but
when you hit a certain level of
suffering and you think there is nothing
else
you can look back at these times
in that darkness and be like man if i
didn't
know the depths and the levels of
darkness
i wouldn't be able to enjoy this moment
right now
so there was a time when
i used to pack a gun with me everywhere
orlando was an orlando used to be and
orlando still kind of has a very
um you've got the disney side and you
got the
super rough like home invasions like
they'll come and run in your house
they'll
shoot you in the middle of walmart
that's like florida
right right okay
sometimes i pray for my kids still out
there but still um
you know florida was you know florida is
a
is a state where you have your stand
your ground
law so you can come into somebody's
residence and they can shoot you
on self-defense and
that's it it's called stand your ground
or castle law
which is so interesting in light of
what's going on with brianna taylor
right now yeah
right and then also you mentioned to me
that
the cop who put his knee on george
floyd's neck
now is living down the street or was
living down the street
yeah from from my kids yeah in florida
that's insane
yeah which isn't a that's that's a whole
nother story in itself
but you know just to to bring it back to
this um
you know that was such a that was such a
dark dark time and
and as i said you know for me i used to
pack because
where my parents live it's not a rough
neighborhood but there was a lot of home
invasions there was a lot of breakings
it was
my parents are old and and again
remember i told you i had to move back
in with my parents well after couch
surfing and
yada yada my
so this is the umpteenth time of moving
back with my parents
but if i didn't have you know my
my relationship with my parents now
i used to be scared of them i used to
fear him i used to
now they're like my brother and sister
the relationship is amazing
and this was partly the reason
i'm going to say my job but this this
last thing with my parents
and for them to see how broken i was
was really really deep and and and to
cry with your parents
is even deeper and i don't know if
you've ever had that but when you've
when you're in the presence of your
mother or your father and you are legit
all crying in despair it's a
hard hard pill to swallow man and it was
and it was hard to come home knowing
that i lost everything
and it was hard knowing to come home
that i had three kids that i'm still
paying for
but i'm still paying for that school i'm
still paying for
everything and i can't talk to him
because she won't let me talk to him
so all this stuff is going down
meanwhile i'm still paying for the house
i'm still paying for the minivan i'm
still paying for all their extra
curricular activities and i'm at home
at my parents house
with a shotgun underneath the bed
did you have a sense
you know this idea that that that
you can't be a phoenix without the ashes
right like yeah
this idea that you're being you're being
burned for
a reason that there's a purpose or that
there's something
to be mined and learned from this
experience so that you can
emerge more fully integrated i mean with
all of this
spiritual education behind you you must
have been able to hold on to some aspect
of that or to believe
or to choose to believe that there is
some kind of
purpose or lesson to be learned here
i did but it was very little in the
grand scheme of things yeah
it was very little because although i
had
the running that kind of took me out of
that space right because i would run
and run was then that becomes your new
healing that becomes my new healing
mechanism right
so i had the running that became my new
healing mechanism and
and i could grab onto that and i still
had my spiritual faculties
but i wasn't leaning on to him as much
as i could so in that
in a room i had
my friends you know i had a really good
i have a really good
girlfriend of mine her name is christina
my ex-wife was named christina my best
friend was christina at the time
christina was the first person that i
went to when i got
essentially at the house and i was couch
surfing she looked after me basically
for two summers
because i was broke she looked after me
along with my parents and really
kind of helped me get back on track
and then as i said you know because in
that time
i had probably contemplated suicide four
or five times
and you know the the the one story that
i was trying to bring up and i really
bring the story was the story was
me in the parking lot of
orlando zen center friend of mine
sandra bianco
love sandra sandra was the one who said
you need
something come to the temple
at the time the time i didn't know what
the tempo was she said come to the
temple
i was like okay so i drive up there
and i've got this big springfield
45 next to me and at the time i
just got off the phone with my ex we had
just got into a major argument she's
asking for more money for the house
i'm i'm literally just like shaking and
i'm just
shaking uncontrollably and i'm like do i
just do it right now
i'm looking at the gun i'm in front of
the temple
[Music]
i'm looking at the gun
and then i'm like all right [ __ ] it i'm
gonna go do whatever this [ __ ] thing
is
i don't know what i'm gonna get into but
i'm gonna do it
and that ended up becoming my
that that could have been my last day on
the f
and instead i chose to sit in front of a
wall in silence
for an hour and a half
that's heavy man i wonder how many
people
show up at a zen center with a gun
contemplating suicide
yeah wow and that was
and that's what led me to you know
subsequently that was that was really
when i was literally crawling on the
bottom like
i don't know if i can make it
that was kind of like the ladder that
was like yes you can
and i went into that i went into that um
i went into that sangha or
what in in buddhist term we call
spiritual community
and i remember having my first dharma
talk with the abbot her name was claudia
she was a white-bodied lesbian and
she broke it down for me so real and raw
as a zen buddhist does
because you know you never get really
anybody who knows about us in buddhism
you never get
a straight answer right yeah you gotta
go
confounding yeah but i do i i
i mean on some level did you walk into
that thinking come on man like i've i've
done
i've been in i've been into daoism i've
been into rastafari i've done i've done
all these things like what is this place
going to teach me that i don't already
know
i really did yeah i really did i really
did and especially when it was this
number
freaking all white folk in there i was
like oh really
white people pretending like
so i'm like oh really i was like okay
and those people ended up becoming my
saviors
like you would not believe and there
were some young folk in there and then
ended up seeing more diverse crowd but
at first it was just like what am i
getting into
and then they're chanting in korean and
then there's this big bowl and there's
this
huge buddha and then you're having to
sit
in front of the wall mm-hmm
but that was so inevitable in orlando
yeah in orlando it's still freaking out
in san francisco
or in no no in orlando
off south street in orlando
and i ended up coming out of that
so i'm not going to say like
buddha under the bodhi tree but i it was
near enough
it was near enough and
i just came out of that and i was
it was it was powerful so came out of
that meaning your first
that was the first session that was the
first session it was that
quickly it was it was that deep it was
that deep
it was so profound being in silence
for for an hour hour and a half
and then to talk to that abbot and the
words that she
left me because i gave it to her i was
like i was literally like i
had nowhere to turn like this was it for
me
and she was like i don't know if it's
gonna be it for you
uh-huh but you're gonna realize sooner
or later
if it really was like [ __ ] you
right so
i left out of that um
i just came out of a relationship
um and i was
you know i had a friend who had just
died not too long back i just got out of
a serious
serious relationship i thought this girl
was the one boom boom boom
and at the same time i had a friend that
we had conversed and
um i just had a liking to her on
instagram right
so low and behold this relationship
that was this based on a friendship
ended up kind of growing
and she was buddhist too so
at this time i'm finding so much love
and compassion
in this zen center that i'm just
it put me on a projection and in this
projection
i start meditating then i start
meditating every day
and prior to this meditation wasn't part
um
i had kind of put it under the rug
because i was just dealing with real
[ __ ]
uh-huh meditation was there but it
wasn't really in
the the
the way that i was moving now
because meditation was there and i would
meditate but it was like
this ain't working it just weren't
working because i would still have
contemplations of doing what i needed to
do in order to offer myself or
this ain't working because if it did i
wouldn't be in a situation i was
right but then
it became
my solace so now i've got
meditation and then i have running
and i still have my friends here who
were looking after me
and kind of giving me advice and telling
me you are gonna make it but it was
really these two
so then these two suddenly started
coming together
slowly and surely and then i started
really seeing the power because now
i'm starting to feel good about myself
i'm starting to if you if i can make an
analogy of like
a gumby you know those things that are
doing like this and
so i was just flat now
i'm starting to get air pumped in me so
now i'm starting to learn about
compassion
equanimity now i'm starting to learn
about discernment in its highest regard
now i'm learning about all these koans
that are kind of interweaving and
and and i'm starting to use these
commands in my life
and i'm starting to see things change
and now
i'm going showing up to court or showing
up to these mediation
battles with compassion
now i'm dealing with my ex-wife with
compassion oh you don't want to let me
talk to the kids
i'm good with that i know it's gonna
happen
because i'm doing good things i'm paying
bills
and paying even though i could have
stopped
and said i'm not paying this i'm not
doing this i was like
i'm gonna do it and then i started
showing up to certain things
and i started showing up for myself
and then that the confidence started
building and then my parents started
seeing like
they started smelling the incense coming
out of my room right
because i'm burning like four or five
incenses at a time
they're seeing like you know the mat out
in the middle of the living room
or you know they come in from my mom's
doing a walk on my dad's out in the
garden and he sees me
like chanting so this is becoming real
now
and now they're seeing it at work
because now
my 15 minute breaks that i would be
going in the bathroom crying because i'm
leading a team
like one of the biggest scenes i've
become a global
all-star you know for whole foods the
nine yards i'm still breaking down
crying in the middle of my work sessions
but now that breakdown is now me
meditating in the break room
and now other people are seeing me
meditate now they're asking questions
and then that was
like the phoenix starting to get his or
her
you know wings back and then all this
hate and resentment and aggression
started transmutating
right so all those base metals started
changing into gold
slowly but surely and then i met this
woman
and she's like come to l.a
never been to la in my life and at this
time i'm still working now i'm working
four jobs now i'm still working whole
foods
40 hours a week i'm working massaging 25
hours a week
i'm working lift like 10
15 hours a week and then i'm just doing
odd jobs here and there for the homies
so it's like 80 90 hours a week of work
and then in between that i'm just your
practice i'm just
and you're running my practice and my
running and
are you able to register or calibrate
in your own mind the changes that you're
undergoing or
oh yeah so there's a thing in the
recovery community where
you don't feel like you're making
progress and it's only when it's
reflected back to you
from other people because you can't see
it on a day-to-day basis and you don't
feel like you're making progress and
other people will be like you look
different
yeah you're holding yourself differently
exactly
you know in the eye in a way that you
weren't three months ago
exactly exactly and all of that started
happening
all of that and um
it was just a change i had a really good
friend named zach who
is uh
he's like my he was like etn
but in the florida version right
and i will he lived in a place called
new sumana which is right outside of
orlando
and he was like he was like a monk house
and i would go visit him
on the weekends and
it was just really great because i would
have
a spiritual brother who was locked in
just like me
and we would meditate together in just
hours and hours we'd cook food and just
talk and that was so
good for me because in this time now
you know all this stuff is happening um
you know now i'd started seeing my kids
and i would get them every other weekend
[Music]
so um you know one of the biggest things
was
um how do i support my kids on
such a minimum you know there would be
times i would have to save
you know ten to twenty dollars just to
make sure that i had enough on the
weekend to make sure that i would look
after them
because all my money was elsewhere wow
so you know that was that was that was
really good but it was really good
because i started becoming a parent
i was a parent but i wasn't really a
parent i was a parent because now there
was no
ex-wife telling me what to do it was me
holding my kids
so i had relationships with all of them
and it was rough
and it was hard for them it was hard for
them to see me in such a sunken state
but
as the buddhism evolved i started
evolving as a human
and it started making relationships with
them even more
pliable and more tangible and then i was
teaching them
the things that i was learning and at
that time you know you're teaching a
little 12 year old
that at the time my oldest woman was 12
and she was like what the hell are you
talking about
my eight-year-old is like that i just
want to watch peppa pig i could care
less what you're doing
but they started to see a change in me
and and you know
um you know my my daughter now is my
so so in the know now
that we can have these conversations and
talk about buddhism and
you know all the stuff that's happening
but um they had to see it
and and as i grew um i started having
more confidence in myself and started
realizing that let's get back to that
spiritual faculty
so then i grew and as that practice grew
the run and grew
then i found uh i i i found
uh aikido and at the time you don't have
enough
going on right come on man i need a new
modality
yeah new modalities so i found a keto
uh-huh so aikido is was amazing because
i'm going through the zen buddhism
and we're going for aikido and boom boom
boom
um so then i meet this girl in l.a
um and she just rocks my sock off she
she flies me out here
and we have this love affair for the
better on instagram on instagram
so we have this love affair all right
um but here i am i'm still a householder
i'm still
you know i'm not really cool right i'm
not cool i'm still wearing dad jeans i'm
still
you know i mean i'm still because i
can't afford anything i can't afford new
products you weren't rocking like all
the fly [ __ ] no
not at all not so i'm like you need to
take me shopping dude you gotta sort out
my closet because you
gotta go i see you we were joking
during the shoot we were talking about
our daughters because our daughters are
about the same
age and i was expressing you know
my challenges and trying to connect with
them and you're like
dude my daughters don't think i'm cool
and i'm like they don't if your
daughters don't think
you're cool we're all hopeless no no
no you know it's funny because i get
people like dm and me like dude your
stylism like
my door is like your african man gown is
killing me daddy it's killing me
what does she want to wear what could
you put on that
impressive well well you know it's funny
because now it's
when i look back at what i was rocking
and now she's like
rocking the white air force ones and the
car hearts and the stuff like that but
you know it's it's so funny how
you know i i'm not cool i'm not cool on
any
on any given day's for you dude you are
cool not to them i'm not
yeah but um so so yeah
i wasn't cool and and here you know to
give you a background
my girl um melinda
is she's an ex plus size model
she's a fashionista she is like
you know she dated models she dated
rappers the whole nine yards so i'm
looking at this woman and i'm like what
is she even
how does she even see me this dude in
orlando working at whole foods
exactly i'm working four jobs i'm not
cool
at this time on instagram i was you know
i'm
posting records and talking about my
life going through divorce people ain't
really messing with me for style and
running and all that stuff
but she was like no you're amazing
um you know i want to kind of kick it
with you and yada yada so that form
that relationship happened so hold on a
second
clearly it's a vibration that you're
putting out right
like and that vibration is a reflection
of all the inner work that you've done
yes like that
has power and potency like that is a
real thing yeah but if she was sitting
across from me right now and i was to
say to her
tell me what it is that you saw
specifically in hock
at that time what would she say
i think she would probably say i saw a
power that he didn't see that he had in
himself
exactly yeah she
she she would probably say that i saw a
power and a light
that he didn't see that i saw
and and i got a credit i mean i tell
people a little while that's my business
manager that's my lawyer
that's my you know when you and i know
you have a strong amazing wife so you
know
um and we
we we talk about this in therapy because
that that's another thing that was a
game changer for me was therapy
but we talk about this all the while
like
she is legit like the first woman
that i have ever been with that has made
me feel
that i can achieve and do anything in
all of its totality
the first and probably kick your ass too
and kick my ass at the same time that's
the best combination
yeah yeah the easiest it's not the
easiest
it's not the easiest but um
what she has done for my life has been
nothing
short of amazing
um she is one of the reasons why i can
say that i'm sitting in front of you
today because
she gave me the
she gave me that red pill to say that
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
and it doesn't matter that you're in
orlando and it doesn't matter that
you're working all of these jobs yada
yada if you want it you can have it
it's all up to you but i can tell you
that you're going to get it
and i'm going to help you get it um
so um something really major happened
um between me and my ex and
i'm in orlando and the relationship's
great
running's great buddhism is great the
martial arts are great
but i'm still not where i'm still
working for jobs i'm still not making
the money that i'm
you know child support is coming out of
every paycheck
i'm barely cutting the mustard
and then something really cataclysmic
happens
that really offsets my whole being with
this divorce and yada yada
and i made the decision and it was such
a hard decision to leave my kids in
orlando
but i wasn't getting anywhere and in
order for me to be the best person that
i had to be
for them i had to leave i had to leave
orlando
there had to be people who thought that
was the wrong thing oh dude
i would say probably 80 to 90 percent of
the people who
were in orlando said to me leave your
kids how are you gonna
how to i mean my parents were devastated
my parents were devastated
they didn't really have a relationship
with my ex-wife anyway so for them they
were like i'm never going to see my
grandkids again
and um and then for my
my younger one the two youngest it
really didn't really affect them
but it affected my oldest one
um where she really didn't want to
mess with me
and that was a pivotal part of her life
right she was
12 years old i think at the time
11 or 12. so it was a pivotal part of
her life and she had seen
all the stuff that had gone on in the
space of me and her mother being
divorced
they'd gone through a lot as kids and
then here you are now your dad's about
to move to la
and then on top of that i have all these
people telling me
you're not gonna make it it's super
expensive you're working four jobs how
the [ __ ] do you think you're going to
make it in la
right right where the rent's you know 10
times what it is exactly
so i come to la and
um you know it was rough that first year
was really rough and i was just trying
to
navigate myself and then i'm still going
through the heat of the divorce because
the divorce is still going on
and then i'm meeting this woman who i'm
madly in love with but we never lived
with each other and then we got a
stepson
or i got a stepson now oh wow so
you go from instagram love affair did
you just move in with her directly
directly and then you're a stepdad and
then i'm a stepdad
holy [ __ ] dude
right it could have gone all kind of
crazy
it could have gone sideways all kind of
crazy all kind of crazy
and you know um
there's so many sidebars with you know
her previous marriage divorce how rough
it was for her
you know and and the thing that i love
about my partner
is that she has her own story of abuse
and
and yada yada and her resiliency
her resilience and her power and her
coming into this and as rough as it was
the first year
um we both had came out of so many
damage and detrimental life-changing
situations that we were like
no this is going to work
so then i met these crazy kids in
koreatown called koreatown run club
i ran with a different whole bunch of
different crews in town
but i met these guys career town run
club
and at the time you know run crews were
a thing
in la but not as big as new york yeah
not at all
not at all not at all it's not like
bridge runners or black roses
or anything like that it wasn't like
that yeah so
it's still not really it isn't that you
created a thing
don't go for it
i wouldn't say created but so
so then i met with these cats
and um i started running with them and i
loved what they were all about
and then months go by and then they
realized that i do tai chi they realize
that i'm into mindfulness and meditation
yadda yadda and at that time i was
i'd come to l.a i wasn't
really uh immersed in the zen i kind of
gone into insight
and there was a group of crazy cats by
the name and i'm sure everyone knows
them especially if you're in recovery
against the stream and noah levine
and uh dharma punks right punk's right
so i came to la and melinda was already
part of that crew
already so then i came in
and then what really what i really loved
was there was
buddhists that looked like me i mean
legit look like me
black tattooed who were like teaching
dharma
and i was like i'm into that
that's what i'm into and you're speaking
my language
so then i met joanna hardy
who is um one of the leading
uh black body dharma practitioners
in the world and she came she was
basically noah's right hand and um
i just really just took a liking to her
and
i just really loved what insight was
about and then i started reading books
on jack cornfield and
arjun char and um
the whole thai forest monks and i and
then i started learning about for
passion and then
lo and behold thomas and claudia who i'd
known for years
were doing for partialness too and i was
like
for passionate
i was like okay this is a real deal oh
you got
you have to spend 10 to 14 days in
silence
with no phone and you know follow
precepts and yada yada and you can still
look like this
and still be black-bodied and still have
tattoos i was like
let's go let's go because as much as i
love zen
and i love zen buddhism and the zen
philosophy
um it's very whitewashed i'm not gonna
you know it's very whitewashed and you
know the thing with buddhism is
is that um we're coming into a new state
of buddhism now where
you are seeing a lot of diversity you're
seeing a lot of bipark showing up
you're seeing a lot of the alphabet
lgbtq
you know indifferent everyone's coming
into it now
whereas back when i first was messing
with buddhism there wasn't so much of
that
so um you're seeing
the ruth kings you're seeing the joanna
hardy's you're seeing
um the llama rod owens coming out of
this
where they're bringing a radical space
of dharma into this
space of buddhism now and that is that
was what was really attractive and
remember
as i've always said i've always wanted
to be kind of a game changer
so being with this crew and then being
with this career town crew
i was like how am i going to really make
a name for myself in la and how can i
really
bring all of these wells together so
these guys were like
do you want to become a captain i was
like yeah why not
they said if you're going to be a
captain bring your own twist to being a
captain
i was like okay you sure about that like
yeah
and then they they threw me another
caveat and they said and then we want
you to teach tai chi to runners
ah and i was like you're giving me this
bone too
i've been waiting my whole life for this
right are you still doing the
the vibram's thing no there's nothing no
no
no i gave those up i'm nike boy now i'm
like give me the 4
give me the next percent whatever so
and that was the real cool thing about
running with krc was because they had an
affiliate
association with nike so i was able to
be part of a capsule for the nike epic
reacts
um i was able to do all these really
cool capsules
and in this time one of
the really co-conspirators of
krc making the group as it was
had passed away and that really
did a lot for running and the community
so in that i want to say this was right
before the la marathon
uh 18. these guys had said to me we want
you to become a captain
so then what had happened was
i was like if you want me to be a
captain i want to bring mindfulness
because that's my bag
i want to show the power of meditation
and how you can use
um how running is a meditation and how
you can use mindfulness
in that space of running and then
that blue and yeah the intersection of
mindfulness and running was
i mean how long ago was this oh god this
was
i mean it had been going on but 2018 was
when i really started implementing
it not that long ago but that's right
when those two worlds were starting to
intersect in a meaningful way so
it was almost like a right place right
time thing for you
yeah and you had this like robust you
know decades
of experience leading up to this and
you're just
you're like perfectly suited but i still
had imposter syndrome
i still had imposter syndrome because
you because i'm i mean i'm in california
i'm in l.a where there's everyone you
know i mean you've got the down to
santos you've got the tc
seafood you've got every you know you've
got all
you know you had a few big runners you
know my friend marquise you had the
the noel's and then um then you started
having
you know luminaries coming into l.a you
started having knocks the noxies coming
into la now you started having
people started taking oh this is what
la's about you had the blacklist
um blacklist is a really big run crew
out here and then you had krc
now is blacklist the one that's downtown
yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah so but then
krc had this big nike epic reaction
people have started knowing about
kathleen through run crew culture
and then and lo and behold oh you're
doing mindfulness and running now
so then you have people from korea
australia
then people started coming and doing
articles on the crew
and then articles on me and how i was
bringing this into selection of
mindfulness and running
so before you know it um
i went from being this kind of small
time crew captain to now i'm on a
i'm on a magazine in france
i'm on a magazine you know uh
uh spiritual run gurus of
la or you know the world and then
um i had this company this tempo
magazine from australia came out they
did a whole bit on chaos
then they came out and did a story on me
so then the next thing you know i'm
getting
um podcast requests people are asking
oh come on this podcast and then um
i'm doing little pop-ups of mindfulness
running
collabos and then um
these group of crazy mexican brothers
call me
and they're like hey we love what you're
about
do you want to come run in chiapas and
teach mindfulness to runners
and i was like yeah you'd never run on a
trail once
never yeah
right and here i am in the middle of
chiapas
running in the jungle and
that was like but but you know was
i i was looking at these guys the guy's
the name era libre
and um it's mao and emmy and danielle
and i looked at them and i was like wow
these are really
some really interesting characters and i
and you probably know noxie had did
their first
run right i do know that yeah so
um i mean you and knox is very you know
there's a lot of overlap
yeah and yeah kind of what you guys are
about yeah and then you add another one
into the mix you've got
charlie dark from random in london he's
another component of that
so so you had these guys named air libre
and they're doing this thing and they're
talking about spiritual running in the
wilderness
and i'm like okay so we started this
internet conversation
and the next thing you know they're like
we want you to come to chiapas we want
you to leave this
thing in chiapas with us i was like
count me in
never been to mexico never been you know
hadn't even the element of traveling
was so thought foreign to me like eight
years ago my parents are giving me money
to re-re-do my passport
my english one and my american one and i
ended up spending it on
the mortgage or something like that
because i'd like because my ex-wife told
me a long time ago
if you're thinking about traveling it
ain't happening
you're a stay-at-home dad yeah that's
all you need to think about well the
other thing that's interesting
unlike knox you're not out like
crushing it you know on the track or on
the road you're not
out you know podium yeah
standing on the podium at ultras or
anything like that like you're
you're you know you're like middle of
the pack dude yeah how do you even run a
marathon
yeah yeah i'd rather run one minute
it's really tipped toward the spiritual
side and the education side of this
and it's not about like the running
pedigree other than the fact that you're
like a running enthusiast yeah who loves
running and running you know it was deep
because i i was really
like you know i was a i was fanboy to
noxie and charlie and
and and all these guys and i was just
like wow they got run crews and they're
like
you know i'm looking at noxie noxie is
like cross country champion when he was
14.
and you know you got charlie who started
running when he was like in his late 20s
and
now he's like running new york and bar
and i'm like looking at these dudes and
here i
am i'm a middle of the road
like eight 7 30 if i'm good
you know what i mean a mile running a
mile
um you know i'm i'd run
maybe a trail here and there but i'm
running the streets that's what i was
you know i'm running 5ks and 10ks in the
streets
i'm running in the heart of gree
koreatown at 10 o'clock at night
that's what i'm known for that's what i
was really known for
like city running like um
did i have dreams and you know dreams of
grandeur of running boston and
and new york yeah i did but then what
had happened was
was i started seeing an evil side of
running
i started seeing like how people were
like really like
you're not even getting paid
to really be putting yourself through
all these rigors
to be like just a ridiculous performance
mindset of it as opposed to
the pure enjoyment and human properties
of it like this is something we didn't
even go into it i don't think enough
how instrumental running was in helping
you get through the divorce and the
experience like
that like what that what that um
did for you the just the ability of
being able to put on a pair of shoes and
go outside and be with yourself
liberation one-on-one
when you talk about liberation you're
talking about complete freedom
mind body spirit soul and that's what
running was for me at that time
um that's what running still is for me
and that's what i try to
impart in people that it's bigger than
running
you know um that was one of the biggest
so i did a capsule for adidas
and they had reached out to me and they
were like can you kind of
you know show and prove how running
really helped you
so i was able to kind of in a in a mini
frame explain my story and one of the
biggest things
that i still use today to to this day is
that it's bigger than running
running is the vehicle but what comes
out of it and a lot of us
are either running away from something
or running to achieve something
and when you add the spiritual component
in that
you realize that it's not about the
metal the metal is
the metal is nothing oh
you you ran boston in two hours and 50
minutes
not to discredit those who about that
life and who want to do that
more power to you but there's something
that is so much more deeper when you run
and for me as much as i was trying to
chase that goal of
you know sub three and whatnot i didn't
la i didn't um give up on that
i just saw that there was a different
angle to that
and i started seeing that there were
other people who saw
running in the same way but it's more
spiritual
there is a spiritual essence and
component of running
there is there is a dynamic
aspect to running when you are able to
tune the mind because it's really a form
of mental gymnastics
it really is a form of meditation in
itself
and when you take away the watch
take away the garmin the sun too or
whatever
and you just run a long piece of road it
is this
you your body your breath
and your spirit and lastly your mind
and your mind can either dictate you and
tell you oh i'm not gonna make it a mile
or two miles or 20 miles or 70 miles
or you can put your mind as the co-pilot
and have that synergy with your mind and
work together
and get to that finish line
and that's what i was able to do in the
aspect of
taking the mind and letting the mind
dictate and tell me
no hawk you can't do this you can't do
this and took the mind
out and used it as a vehicle
along with my body and then put it
together with my spirit
and made a cohesion to where now i say
it's bigger than the running because
there's so much more value
in the run yeah now i can find and
answer questions
i can answer questions on my own life i
can break down okay
why is my marriage not working why
is this not working okay i can do this
to
make better sense of how i talk to my
child
oh this is a different factor
just taking the earbuds out because that
was another piece i used to run with
music and then i took the music
out and then i started listening to the
birds and then i started listening to my
breath
and listening to my feet on the concrete
and then that's when it made
sense and i was like ah
this is why they come hand in hand
so beautifully put it's about the
relationship
with yourself yes right and
irrespective of whether you're winning
races or coming in last place
what did that experience of putting one
foot in front of another
teach you about who you are and who you
can be
exactly and i think that does get missed
in our culture
of biohacking and gps devices
and and the like when we strip it all
away like i'm in the process like you
you went from the barefoot to the
i'm kind of going back because i never
went through the barefoot thing yeah
and i want to feel what that is like
yeah
and i'm trying to retrain myself to run
in that way
and i'm leaving the garment at home and
i'm just going out and
stripped down yeah like full analog
yeah and there's a and you feel naked at
first you're like well it doesn't
count if it's not on strawberry and all
of that and it's like well all right
well what is that discomfort about
what am i what am i you know why do i
feel an attachment to that like what is
that telling me about
my ego you know where is the lesson in
humility here how can i be more
connected to my environment and to
myself
how can i tap into a deeper sense of
wholeness
and oneness with everything and and
that's really
what running is about right you just hit
it right on the head
you know you hit it right whether you're
in koreatown or you're
in the santa monica mountains or in
chiapas yeah
that is available to everybody and i
heard you say this in another podcast
like
it's free yeah you know yeah you got to
buy the shoes
you got to buy a pair of shorts but then
after that
it's free that's it and
and and again when we talk about
liberation what is liberation is total
freedom
so it goes hand in hand it goes hand in
hand
and i think you know you said you you
said it we do take it for granted and
and you know
i'll be the first one to tell you you
know i used to live and die by my
garment i used to live and die by house
you're wearing it right now you know
it's like oh my god but the only reason
why i'm wearing this because
watch i'm not even looking it looks cool
well it does it does but you know um
strava i can't tell you the last time i
made a strava update
it just doesn't you know i have it
but it doesn't serve the purpose like it
used to because
now for me um you know
even when i was 13 000 feet
old me would have been like okay i gotta
you know i got a timeless and i gotta
man i was just in it just to smell the
air i was this in it just to do
the damn thing and just to feel the
experience
and to find that beauty in the suffering
right
um and i think
that's why you know you're gonna have
schools of thoughts and running you're
gonna have
those who are like you know you're gonna
have your nazis
you're gonna have your charlies you're
gonna have your tim ferrisses you're
gonna have your
marioli um your your mario
um fraily exactly you're gonna have
you're gonna have all these different
casting characters within running but we
all serve a different purpose
my purpose is really just to show
one anyone can run two
um black indigenous people of color
have every right to be in running spaces
just as much as
anybody else does um three
that there is such a powerful spiritual
component within running
and that it is actually a great tool for
mental health
and for you to reclaim your sense
of mental clarity um
[Music]
and lastly it just feels good
and it is such a great
tool for tuning the temple
it's karma yoga for your body it really
is
just like you do karma yoga when you're
cleaning your house it is just the same
way you're doing it for your body
you're just doing a little bit of common
yoga for your body
when you look back on this crazy
trajectory and now you are this
you know you are a running influencer a
mindfulness
influencer who gets flown you know to
crazy
places to hang out with super cool
people and talk about the things that
you love i mean there has to be
a little bit of like pinch me to the
whole thing like how did i get to this
place
i mean you mentioned imposter syndrome
but on some level like
you know i feel like you're owning it
right and when you look back and think
about that time that you're sitting in
the parking lot at whole foods and
crying in your car
um you have to know that like
there was this maybe not a plan but
there's a
thread like there's a through line
there's a theme
to all of this that have led you to this
place and yes when you look
backwards it's always 20 20. it looks
like everything
everything all these experiences that
you've had have created this like
incredibly nutritious soup that have
contributed to you being
you know the person that you are like
the only person actually who can like do
what you
do like you have this unique vibration
and expression to
you know the advocacy that you share
with everybody but how do you
like think about that
um that's a really good question um
man it's you know i think
for me
it took me 46 years to get like you know
i i i i do have those pinched myself
moments like
um i was just talking to brian levine
from 10 000
who they told me to give you a little
wink win
um you know i was just talking to brian
yesterday
and um he was just like
you know just so great to have you on
board and you know
what you're doing for running and just
you know you've really
and and i had to really just look at
myself and just like
man is he talking about me and
you know even just talking with conrad
last week
and we were having this deep
conversation and here i am like i just
finished watching meru
uh-huh i just finished watching this guy
like
you know literally be a be a superhero
dude yeah like he's hanging off a
freaking cliff
like you know just eating couscous on a
cliff
for like something crazy like 17 days
and here he is just like telling me
it was such an honor being in your space
and i think about those times when i was
in that car park
and i think about the times when
you know i think about the time when i
told my parents that i was living in the
house that my dad made
like crying like are you [ __ ] kidding
me
but here i am at 46.
having conversations with rich roll
having calling conrad anchor my brother
having
these stories and having these people
that have all played
major roles in my life
all the way down to hr's road manager
that i spent the the crazy time with
the guys from to the curb that
fueled me paving the way to get
opportunities to be in south by
southwest and
even up to now just the fact that
um i'm having conversations with
specialized bikes
um yeah we didn't even get into like the
whole cycling yeah we haven't even
gotten to the cycling things the next
iteration
of what you're doing you know what i
mean so i mean you know
cycling mountain climbing running
um you know teaching at spirit rock last
year
um being asked to you know
um teach tai chi in a place that is the
the home of american buddhism to teach
with
you know to have somebody like jack
cornfield following me
to have you know it's this if you'd have
told me this
eight nine years ago when i was working
four jobs and thinking to myself there
was no way
that i'm gonna be
in situations like this or there would
be no way that you would tell me that
i'd be running
up a volcano in chiapas that i would be
on a on a record of one of my
idols at the time this guy named stick
from deadpress
oh yeah and then i'm on his album
that's pretty cool at 46 years old yeah
fellow vegan yeah
you know and i'm talking to my 16 year
old
and we're just talking about life
and i told her about the situation me
being in wyoming
and she was the one who told me to do it
just these things i i
i one i
bow in humility a thousand times over
and there's a saying that
nice guys always finish last that's
[ __ ]
and it's [ __ ] in the fact that you
can be a good person
you can be a good person and live your
authentic life
if you just do the work
just do the work and we are in a such a
cookie-cutter society where people
don't want to do the work i had to do
the work for
x amount of years and i had to go
through so much suffering
so yeah it looks good on the ground now
i'm like you know i've got my shea butt
legs i'm you know i got the freshest
gear on you know what i mean i'm
hanging out with rich i'm hanging out
with conrad i'm hanging out with all
these luminaries
but you don't know what it took to get
to this point
it took a lot of hard work it took a lot
of
years of thinking that it was a failure
thinking that i couldn't make it
to now where i just as i said
i you know i i talk to my plants i sage
my my you know i sage my girl i sage me
i saved the house i
i do these rituals where i you know mess
with my little sound bowl and i meditate
and i just give thanks man because
i just i i i really just
i paid into my comic bank without even
knowing it
um yeah well i can hear the the
gratitude
and the humility is unmistakable and
it's so
inspirational and empowering and i think
one of the
things that strikes me the most about
your journey is the fact that you're
like a product of the prophets that walk
among us
right the anonymous prophets who are
everywhere when you're
a seeker and you're able to identify
them and avail yourself of what they
have to teach you
it's not like you said i want to learn
aikido or tai chi or yoga or acupuncture
and i'm going to travel to
you know sit at the feet of the the
world master
you just you found these people in your
community you just bumped up against
these people
and you had an openness and a
willingness to say i'm gonna check this
out
and you know through a thousand
iterations and versions of that you know
it kind of forged you into the person
that you've become and i think what's
instructive
is that is the fact that that these
people are
in our communities right like you're in
orlando
you're working all these jobs and you
are able to find these people and carve
the time out
to you know learn and grow and it was
slow and it was hard and you got
[ __ ] crushed yeah yeah and you
leveraged that experience to
just deepen your commitment to your
spiritual practice
and your faith was tested but you've you
know
you've persevered but it's really just a
it's a product of showing up for that
experience right
yeah and and and and keep on showing up
you know it's i mean i don't know where
this chapter is going to lead there's so
many different chapters to this book
and i and i and i think as i as i listen
to myself
and as i reflect back on
all these journeys to where i'm at now
humility is a really big piece it really
is a big piece
and and you know somebody had asked me
the other day
what is your purpose
and i and i just said this to be a good
person
i don't know what does that mean to you
like how do you define that
being a good person i mean you know i
could go through the precepts
you know yeah yeah i could go on and on
about that but i mean realistically
it's just to treat people how they are
supposed to be treated
to really amplify those who don't have a
voice
um to really speak for the justice
or the injustices of the world being
that i have a voice
being that i have a voice that can
orientate my words pretty clearly and
very well
um then
there are many bodies black bodies
indigenous bodies that don't have that
capacity you don't have the
space to do that um you know
for example just the fact that to climb
on the side of a mountain
there's black folks who have probably
never even seen the bottom of a mountain
but what i can do is show
that yes you do have the right
you have the ability and you have to you
you have
the tools to do that so
you know something that just to bring it
back full
circle when i when i when i talk to my
parents now
you know they're proud of where i've
come
and it's not even so much on a monetary
level it's just to know where i
came from what could have happened
what may have happened and to what has
transpired now
has been just for them to say how happy
they are
knowing that they could leave the surfer
any time and that i've made them
somewhat proud
my kids same thing you know i have
conversations with my 16 year old like
every day
rich and it's like so empowering
whereas four years ago she didn't want
to talk to me
she didn't want to talk to me and
you know and here we are with this this
woman named melinda who
was the same person who was like be
patient hark
she's going to come back around the same
person who was like be patient
these opportunities that you're looking
for are gonna happen
they're gonna happen having people like
that so you know i
i you know humility again is that such a
big piece gratitude the matter the
the the the actual practice
because i think people get caught up in
the glamor and the glitz and the
face value of something but they don't
understand
the inner science and in the mechanism
of it and i think coming into spaces
like this
and having an opportunity to talk to you
because um
i i realize that i have a privilege just
like murder was talking about it
we're so blessed to have this privilege
where we have publications
that we're on that we have these
podcasts on but you can
bet your bottom [ __ ] dollar but i
will amplify
me this color this culture
to the tenfold yeah because i've been
given that platform feel that
responsibility i do
i do the ancestors would the ancestors
would be ashamed if i didn't
yeah and so how does that
translate into how you think about and
communicate
around what is happening in america
right now like as a
as a black man in america and somebody
who
has been studying these various
spiritual traditions for
a long time that inform how you
respond and react and and and
talk about what's occurring
i'm interested in in how you process all
of that i mean we're in this
incredible moment of upheaval of social
activism
of of you know civil rights and civil
rights violations
and i would i would imagine you wake up
in the morning
thinking long and hard about what is the
right thing for me to say like how do i
fit in here and what is my
responsibility in terms of
how i communicate and channel these
spiritual principles
and how does that meet or gel
with um what's expected of me
in you know in in this in this kind of
crazy moment yeah like what i'm supposed
to say
yeah and it's a great question right
that's such a great question because
you know like just this morning i woke
up
um and uh
you know the the the first thing i i
i post one of the first things i post is
uh
this young brother named toby um
in giveaway i think is i i think is uh
pronounced saying is uh arrest the
killers of briana taylor and it was one
of the first things i posted
um you know it's
it's one of those things where
it's tiring it is tiring
and it is very exhaust exhausting
having to explain over and over and i'm
not saying just in
in this situation because i love we're
talking about this but
just in general the the the landscape
of the black experience and the black
black culture is that we are tired
and you know i don't want to get on a on
a kick because i've read some of the
comments on youtube with past people who
talk about black lives matter and
some of your people are like not having
it they're not feeling it
but hey man yeah i mean you know
those people can say whatever they want
you know what i mean but i i hear what
you're saying like i got
that same sense from john sally he's
like yeah i've been around this block so
many times man
yeah it's it's it's getting to a point
where
we yeah i mean it's
it's it's tiring exhausting it's it's
very
you know to watch a dehumanizing of a
race of people
on a regular basis it's there's a two
there's a two-way street because
i feel like there's a renaissance
so to speak
like
um black excellence is at an all-time
high
um you're seeing you know um
rest in paradise chadwick bozeman but
you know with chadwick
with the um the michael
b jordan's the uh the jonathan
uh majors that are coming out these
black actors that are coming out
you have um black scientists
you have um black broadway actors and
actresses you're getting
so much blackness in its purest
and most beautiful form really in the
public iron lens and being showcased
at the same time you're seeing the
degradation and the dehumanization
of black folks in this country
um the mass shootings and so forth
and how i've been able to navigate it
um in my space is
something that uh a a a black body that
i know
dr reverend um angela kyoto who
brought out a pivotal book not too long
back called radical dharma
and again with dr lam um llama rod owens
just brought out a book rage with fire
um you know i'm leaning on a lot of my
contemporary uh peers and
and and people like joanna i'm i'm
leaning on them because
i'm seeing how they're you know
navigating in their spiritual spaces the
dr ruth kings
um and even going back to the james
baldwins and the fred hamptons and
you know just going back and studying
joe
um joe george jackson um
soledad brother the writings from from
him
i'm having to really
realize that i do have a voice
and you know i'll be the first one to
tell you that
i'm introverted but i have a big mouth
okay i do have a big mouth
um but i do feel that
when you hold yourself in such a
spiritual order
you have that rod right you have that
stick that's holding your back
up that's holding you in front of the
masses that's like i have to show up
i have to show up in my spiritual sense
at the same time
um you know as much as i want to smash
every race
racist [ __ ] in the face that's not
dharmic of me that's not gonna work
um so that's where the middle path comes
in and but it always talks about the
middle path right
that is where you're not
just going full floss in your full force
in the asceticism
but you're not just being lackadaisical
and being like oh
well buddha will work it out you have to
meet somewhere in the middle
and i think my middle is really
engaging my community
in their spiritual practice and telling
them don't lose sight of your spiritual
practice because it is what has got you
here
it is your foundation it is
it is your way of um holding yourself
accountable
on holding your spiritual discipline
accountable at the same time
um let your voice be heard and let your
voice be heard
in a way that you are attacking the
system in a different way
so if that means protesting but doing a
silent protest
then go ahead and do that if it means um
attacking the system and attacking it
from a different way from a social
justice standpoint using your means of
social
activism as instagram or facebook or
stuff like that
doing it on that medium um or being out
in the streets and educating
um you still have to have somewhat of a
foundation
and that's where i feel like my buddhism
is my spiritual foundation
on top of my activism so even though
there is dharma there
it is radicalized because i am mindful
that there is stuff of the world
happening
i am mindful that the brianna's the the
the freddie gray's the
the armor the the ahmad aubrey's the
george floyd's
all these atrocities are happening so
what i have to do in my own capacity
is educate those who are not educated
at the same time educating those
who are educated in a different way
teaching them a different way of
attacking it
and at the same time showing them that
you can still be
spiritual as [ __ ] and still be woke as
[ __ ] at the same time
right maintaining your equanimity yeah
not being
reactive yes sort of channeling your
inner jedi
and just standing in your strength to
speak from a place of
experience and wisdom but
also with some level of kind of
distance or dispassion so that you're
not getting caught up in a bunch of
[ __ ] craziness exactly exactly yeah
yeah because you've seen that and we've
all seen that we've seen that
i've said you know i'm not gonna name
names but i've seen those who were
somewhat on that mission and on that
like no we need to do this we do this
and then something came out about them
or somebody's saying something and then
they're looking like a total wally
and and and and their purpose and their
mission has now been clouded because of
something else that happened
you know i mean so for me
i've been really really really
mindful of how
i really play my part and put myself
in certain positions because
there is a war going on outside
um and
my stance right now is to be both the
sword and the shield
so if malcolm was the sword and martin
was the shield
then i'm trying to be that balance
right because i still got malcolm in me
and i still got a little bit of martin
in me
but i want to bring that together so
for me i feel like i've been given the
voice i've been given a platform
um i still have those revolutionary
tendencies
and i'm still about the revolution but i
still
fall into that same bracket of silent
weapons for silent wars
there's a way of attacking the enemy
that they're not going to know
and that's where the tai chi comes in
because
when hardness attacks hardness
there's not going to be any type of
resolve
but if the hardness finds that softness
that softness is able to yield that
hardness and transmutate and redirect
that energy
and that's what i'm trying to do in my
own certain way
so i'm really trying to elicit the
philosophy of tai chi
along with a little bit of che a little
bit of malcolm
but at the same time bringing a little
particular han and bring a little bit of
mountain
and then bring in the running and
bringing the cycling and bringing them
out and climbing and then add all that
and a little bit a little bit yeah put a
little vegan sprinkles on top
how long you been vegan now god since
end of
95 early 96 right and your your website
is vegan boyfriend
you made me these yes awesome shirts man
i can't wait to rock this yes um shout
out to tony
for that um yeah what's what is the
vegan boy fresh thing all about
so vegan boy fresh is really um just an
umbrella for
just what i'm about um you know the
veganism
the uh that would be your nickname in
the guy richie movie
right yeah yeah it really would be
vegan boyfriend yeah colin farrell's
calling you up
look at the vegan boy fresher yeah there
you go the boxing gym
guy i need you to watch this mate i need
to be in your next movie
um but no it's it's um
it's really so i have pure souls and
mind which is like my run crew
tai chi club psycho bandit crew
and then the umbrella is vegan boy fresh
and that's kind of like
you know it's where i talk about um
mindfulness uh spirituality
you know fashion because it's i love
fashion
um my girl is a fashionista so i got no
choice um
uh veganism which is a very very big
component for me
um and what does that mean to you
i mean it you know before i really
before it was just a health thing right
you know i was really definitely sick i
needed to change my life
i found veganism i found the power of
you know
sprouts and grains and all that stuff
and then i started getting to the
spiritual component of it
and the non the the no a harming of
animals
and that all animals are all sentient
beings
and that does that that factor really
played a big part in character
in my makeup um to the point
you know you know it's easy as even a
mosquito man i don't want to slap a
mosquito that's on my leg i'm like
the first person like come on let me
yeah you know it's
it's to that point but um you know
veganism for me
is is a game changer it's just a game
changer in
um just the fact of the clarity the
mental clarity
that you have when you're not putting
death in your body
when you're not putting you know
lifeless souls in your body and i know
that sounds drastic for any meat eaters
out there but
um you know coming from a point where
even just the way you smell just the way
you
the way you act um
you know there's a saying you know man
can turn animalistic within a heartbeat
where does that come from animalistic
i'm not trying to be animalistic to be
honest with you
i'm just trying to be a human you're
trying to be a bodhisattva yeah
really and truly so for me the spiritual
component of not eating meat is really
big
um and and the physical component like i
feel i'm 46 and you know
because i think i read somewhere about
you know how you were 46 and then
now you're 50 and how you feel and yada
yada there's a feeling that you have
when i i feel
how i should have felt when i was 25 i
feel
at 25 i was 50. i'm now coming into you
know
three years away from 50 and i feel like
i'm 25.
like i get up in the morning and very
rarely do i have i might have an
odd little pain in my knee or something
like that but
um even i remember
you know climbing the mountains the one
day i was saw
af i just remembered like that 13 000
feet
knocked my ass but then the next day i
got some
electrolytes in me some other stuff and
i was good to go
so you know i think there's something to
be said
it's like an elixir it really is
um it it really is like an alexa
veganism for me is like a a new age
taoist elixir
and it just keeps me fresh it keeps me
alive excuse me fresh excuse me vegan
boy
yeah so i love it yeah that's great man
i i mean i couldn't agree more i feel
great i'm
i'm turning 54 next month and you look
[ __ ] amazing
you look amazing yeah don't worry about
it you know
don't worry about that you're killing me
with the beard over there like you're
the first person to sit across from me
with a bigger beard oh i love that i
love
quarantined beer but i love that bit but
some people are like you look like
you're a hundred man
no you don't you know and and i can tell
you
as somebody when 2012
was when you brought your book out right
um
i remember it and it was at a time when
i was really
getting into um
you know my tai chi and veganism and
yada yada and i remember
your book and brendan fraser's book
friday frasier yeah yeah yeah brenda
brazier five
and those two books and i remember
looking at you
and being like dude this guy is
absolutely
amazing like an amazing specimen of a
man
and to know where you came from
to where you're at back then and to
where you're at now
i can tell i can tell you
um now that i know you and seeing you in
the flesh
you are the embodiment of what
somebody who takes their craft and their
their diet
and their well-being into serious into
serious levels you are the epitome of
that and i
totally have such a high respect for you
as far as that because you
you take yourself and you look really
good
and i'll be the first person to tell you
um i am heterosexual to the core
but um you're a good looking cat man and
you keep yourself pretty well
so i have you know my imposter syndrome
is just like
no brim over bro right now no no no no
no
i will i will uh i've been told that
when i'm complimented i should just take
it
take it i'm taking it i appreciate that
um
all right we gotta like land this plane
beautiful
we've been gone we're coming up on three
hours are you serious yeah yeah
jesus no this is great
but i do want to end it with one thought
which is
i said to you earlier that you know
you're somebody who's
you you've immersed yourself in all
these various traditions
and reflecting you know on
what you've learned from all these
respective
ideologies you know is there a unifying
theory and
i don't know that i got an answer for
that but
you know as sort of parting words like
when you
think about everything that you've
learned over the years from
your personal experiences to these
spiritual principles that you've studied
you know what is the message that you
want to give to the person who's
watching or listening
who does feel stuck or is in that place
of working three or four jobs or just in
a cubicle and feeling like
their life um
you know feels like it's at a dead end
like they have this sense that
were they're here to do something and
yet the puzzle pieces just aren't
connecting for them
yeah um
i would definitely say
if you are ever encountering
uncomfortable situations
or you have opportunities that feel
stifling or feel very scary jump into it
jump into it that has been one of the
things
from just traveling the country
traveling different continents um
there's always been an error of me being
kind of scared
nervous and like should i make this
decision
and every time i
talk myself out of it something tells me
do it and that little thing that always
tells me to do it i do it
and 10 out of 10 times it has been the
best decision that i have ever made
those situations that look very very
you might see an end of that light at
the end of the tunnel and that light
might be the size of a pin prick
the thing that i would tell you is crawl
walk
or run to that pinprick because that
pinprick
is going to end up being the size of the
sun sooner or later
but you have to know that that journey
is worth it
and it's almost a liken to
i always tell people like um
my journey has been somewhat like luke
going to the dagobah system
and i don't know what my purpose was
for it i don't know why i do what i do
but i'm glad that i did it and i'm glad
that i
you know went through the stages of my
life that i did
wherever uncomfortable whether scary
whether dark i'm glad that it brought me
to where i was because
at the end of the day i just said [ __ ]
it i'm gonna do it and i did it
yeah i think we all have that little
voice in the back of our head and most
of us
myself included we exert a lot of energy
to quash it
yeah rather than trying to find the
courage to fertilize it a little bit
yeah that's hard
you know it's hard because you have to
go against
basically you know all the inertia of
whatever circumstances you find yourself
in in order to pay attention to that
true voice
because it's telling you to make changes
and
change is hard change is hard if you're
not willing to
undertake some change [ __ ] ain't gonna
change
exactly what's the meaning of insanity
when you keep
expecting different you know you keep
doing the same thing over and over again
expecting different results and that
came that the same exactly
yeah and i think for me that was one of
the things that
i i realized that i had to jump off that
rabbit
wheel and and jumping off that rabbit
wheel was
i i i would jump into another rabbit
wheel and then jump off
until i realized why do you keep jumping
into that rabbit wheel
right and i and i and i think that was
really big for me
um but again you know um
you got to tap in and leaning into your
spiritual faculties
tapping into it and not being afraid and
for men
especially we have this bravado where we
feel like we can't be vulnerable
vulnerability was one of the biggest
tools that helped me break through
some of the ego you know in buddhism
they say diamond cutting cutting
through the rough cutting to the core so
for me vulnerability was that
vulnerability was that tool
for me to cut that diamond in the rough
and
the more vulnerable i was the more
things became liberating
and i think if you can let go of the ego
or strip away that onion of that ego
um because we still all have it
insecurity
not feeling that you're valued all these
things are all part of it but you have
to let it go
because if you don't let it go it's
going to become a big old bag
backpack on your back and it gets
heavier and heavier and heavier
and it breaks you down physically as
well as spiritually
so what i've you'll have your reckoning
with it eventually eventually you know
what i mean exactly
it's either going to be rough and super
hard or nip it in the bud
nip it in the battery nip it in the back
and and you know
i had to you know it was like my mental
meru with that backpack but once i
reached the top of that summit
i let that backpack off and it felt so
good
i think that's a good place to end it so
much love brother
that was beautiful yeah i loved it how
do you feel oh man
that was amazing yeah that was great oh
my god
um come back any time now oh man thank
you
so much for the beginning of a of a
bromance star yeah i really do
i really do yeah super cool so um
if you're digging on hakeem the best
place to track you down it's probably
instagram probably instagram
what's the how come it's not just your
name hawk style
just hawks out because this is stock
kim's dao
oh now i get it i didn't get it i was
trying to figure out what that is
how comes dao um or vegan boy fresh or
veganboyfresh.com
yeah cool all right brother thank you so
much 1000
[Music]
you